What's up y'all? Thanks for being here
as always. Hope everyone is having a
fantastic evening. Welcome to all of you
that are in chat. As more people fill
in, uh if you end up going back and
listening to this, welcome to you as
well. Tonight, we're going to be
addressing a rather common claim and
narrative in the SDA world regarding why
there are various denominations.
This is actually a a interesting topic
within Adventism because on the one hand
like uh Doug Bachelor, they'll want to
tell you, "No, no, no. We're just
another denomination like the rest of
Protestants." But then on the other
hand, like on the uh talk tonight that
Mark Finley gave over on his channel,
they'll want to say, "We're not a
denomination. We're an end times group
that God has called separate from the
the rest of all of that." So this is an
interesting discussion for a number of
reasons as we will see. But this is also
a topic where we get a glimpse into the
restorationist roots of the Adventist
pioneers that undergurs this particular
claim but really the whole system. Uh to
do that I've enlisted the help of
worldwide SDA church president
Ted Wilson. Last time our friend Ted
gave us a hand was for the funeral
service of Mrs. Ellen G. White. head.
Thank you so much for that. He was so
kind to do the introduction if you
remember. And in that introduction, he
exhorted us to read the spirit of
prophecy for yourself. Don't take Pastor
Bachelor's word for it or Pastor
Wilson's word for it. So, I want you to
remember that tonight as well. This will
be key. Remember,
sorry folks, had a little issue here on
my end. Remember that because that's
exactly what we're going to do. We're
going to take him up on his offer. But
first, we aren't going to respond to the
entire video as this is already going to
be a rather long stream. But as always,
I like to state that from the outset,
just so people know, we are simply going
to be using TED as an example and
responding to the entire thing will not
be necessary to make our point. But
before getting into that, I want to
remind everyone that you can visit
answeringadventism.com
where you will find hundreds of primary
sourced articles, responses to common
SDA claims, memes, you can donate, you
can partner with us, and a host of other
things. This search bar is a great great
tool. You can type in phrases. You can
type in texts like proof text. You can
type in themes like contradictions.
And you can come on here and you can
browse to your heart's desire.
Everything that's hyperl. You simply
click on it. It'll take you right to the
source yourself. And you can read to
your heart's desire as much as you want.
and then just hop right on back and
continue reading to see that what we're
saying is not us just talking out the
side of our neck. And remember that
every proof text or verse that is cited
that is highlighted in bold, you can
just hover and it's going to show it to
you right there. So please folks, please
please please be utilizing these
resources. We have all of these
different topics and everything is
organized and categorized. You can come
in here. articles are being added
weekly, uh, daily. If I'm being
completely honest, we're talking about
10 years worth of information that's
been scattered throughout, uh, physical
materials that I have, notes that I've
taken, a variety of things, and they're
all getting put into this Q&A library,
as well as, like I mentioned, a variety
of other things, including the wall of
memes. So, please, please, please,
please, please be utilizing these
resources as these are for you. That's
why this exists. It doesn't exist just
to dunk on Seventh Day Adventism. It's
not just about um you know doing this
for the sake of doing this. Our goal
here, folks, if you're an Adventist, our
goal is for answering Adventism to not
exist. I long for the day that answering
Adventism does not have to be a thing.
That we can close shop and say, "Thank
God he has put under his feet this enemy
of the Lord Jesus Christ, his kingdom,
his gospel." But until then, answering
Adventism will exist. But again, I long
for the day that it doesn't have to
exist. So until then, this resource will
be available and we want you to utilize
it. I want to give a special shout out
and thank you to all of those who have
partnered with us financially. Thank
you, thank you, thank you. You guys make
this thing possible and we are extremely
grateful for your support. You're going
to see some of that put to use here uh
shortly, not too long. should be uh this
month in terms of some of the content
that you're going to see that that's
going to fuel. But um we're then going
to be hitting uh this this winter we're
going to be hitting the uh Google ad
sphere if you will to start competing
with the SDA church which should be
really really fun and really really
good. Now if you've never been an
Adventist, you may not know how vital
and foundational this specific topic is
in the Adventist worldview. It's the
bedrock of the us versus them mentality
that many of the modern SCAS want to
deny that exists. But the reality is
this is a key part of the system. It is
part of the base structure foundation
for their doctrines like that they're
the last day remnant that they're that
they uniquely possess the spirit of
prophecy. Something that they wrongfully
define as we looked at in depth some
weeks ago. But this topic is what props
up the concept and idea of all
denominations except their own as being
a part of Babylon which they attribute
to doctrinal confusion and tradition
with themselves being the bastion of
beacon and light supposedly amidst all
the supposed theological chaos. So
listen closely Christian Ted we want to
continue to take you up on your offer
like I said to read the spirit of
prophecy for ourselves. So that's
exactly what we're going to do. Ellen
White in the Spirit of Prophecy Volume
4, page 232. That's what we're going to
look at here first. Adventist, your
church upholds this as being a thus
saith the Lord statement. Okay. What
does she say? Quote,
the term Babylon derived from Babel and
signifying confusion
is applied in scripture to the various
forms of false and or apostate religion.
But the message announcing the fall of
Babylon must apply to some religious
body that was once pure and has become
corrupt.
Catch that.
The term Babylon must apply to some
religious body that was once pure but
now become corrupt. It can't be the
Roman Catholic Church. That's what she
means by Roman church which is here
meant for that church has been a fallen
in a fallen condition for many
centuries. But how appropriate the
figure is applied to the Protestant
churches, all professing to derive their
doctrines from the Bible, yet divided
into almost innumerable sects. The unity
for which Christ prayed what does not
exist.
Instead of one Lord, one faith, one
baptism, Ephesians 4.
There are numberless conflicting creeds
and theories. Religious faith appears so
confused and discordant that the world
know not what to believe as truth. God
is not in all of this.
What is it viewer?
It's the work of man, the work
of Satan.
Protestantism is not
the work of God. It's the work of Satan.
Get that viewer. Get that. She claims
Protestantism is the result of the work
of Satan. What an utterly ridiculous
statement. But notice, Protestants are
Babylon because they're supposedly
divided into almost innumerable sects,
which show they're not one body, and the
unity that Christ prayed for does not
exist amongst them. God's not behind it.
It's the work of Satan.
The irony of this statement will become
more and more apparent as the evening
goes on. Trust me, dear brother and
sister. Remember this statement
because this is the bedrock for what
we're going to look at tonight. Not the
Bible as Ted's going to try and tell us,
as Adventists are going to try and tell
us. This is why the view is being
projected into scripture. So remember
this.
It's funny. On the one hand, Adventists
will claim that Protestants are
ecumenical stooges who have linked arms
with the papus. On the other hand, we're
supposedly so divided that there's no
unity whatsoever.
It's the abject catch22 that the SDA
church continually operates in. Like,
which one is it? Make up your mind. Are
we supposedly so overunited that we've
over embraced? Or are we so divided that
there's no unity?
Like, make up your mind, Mrs. and Mr.
Adventist. But secondly, it's this topic
of denominations that provide a perfect
example of how the Adventist church has
a target market of Christians. You have
to understand this, folks.
It's those of us that go to church on
Sunday that they have labeled their
biggest threat an enemy.
How do we know this? Ellen White, same
book, next page.
quote, "When the churches spurn the
council of God by rejecting the advent
message,"
she's talking about the 1844 Millerite
message here. The Lord rejected them.
The first angel was followed by a second
proclaiming, "Babylon is fallen, is
fallen, that great city, because she
made all nations drink of the wine of
the wrath of her fornication."
This message was understood by
Adventists to be the announcement of the
moral fall of the churches in
consequence of their rejection of the
first message referring to the first
angel's message. Supposedly this William
Miller message that all these churches
of the day were like you guys are
fanatics. This is not biblical. Well,
that's supposedly by rejecting that God
rejected them. She continues, "The
proclamation Babylon has fallen was
given in the summer of 1844 as a result
of about 50,000 withdrawing from these
churches." So when they heralded this
message and people left their Protestant
churches and came and joined the
Millerite church, that supposedly
fulfilled Bible prophecy.
So the second angel's message of the
Adventist gospel was the announcement
that Protestants and Roman Catholics are
morally fallen due to their rejection of
the first angel's message which again
was William Miller's imminent return of
Christ message of 1844 because
Protestants of the day rejected their
fanaticism. God then supposedly rejected
them. But there also supposedly it was
also supposedly a fulfillment of
prophecy when 50,000 people listened and
joined the Millerite movement. She
continues,
sorry,
in Revelation 17, Babylon is is
represented as a woman, a figure which
is used in the scriptures as the symbol
of a church. A virtuous woman represents
a pure church, a vile woman, an apostate
church. Babylon is said to be a harlot,
and the prophet beheld her drunken with
the blood of the saints and martyrs. The
Babylon thus described represents Rome,
that apostate church which has so cruy
persecuted the followers of Christ. But
Babylon the harlot is the mother of
daughters who follow her example of
corruption. Get that?
Babylon the harlot is the mother of
daughters who follow her example.
Thus are represented those churches that
cling to the doctrines and traditions of
Rome and follow her worldly practices
and whose fall is announced in the
second angel's message. Close quote.
So Roman Catholicism is the harlot of
Babylon and Protestantism is her
daughters. Not my words, folks. It's in
their words.
This is what they don't want to lead off
with in their revelation seminars and
evangelistic efforts, but we're diving
right on in. This is what they think
about you, Christian. So, don't let them
try and pull the we're just another
Protestant denomination card or the hey
brother, and try and cozy up with you.
I'm not saying that the people
themselves may not be nice people, but
this organization is an enemy of the
Lord Jesus Christ.
and Catholics Orthodox Assyrian Church
of the East Coptics, please do not
associate this organization with
Protestantism.
Why is that? As if that statement wasn't
enough.
Quote,
letters and manuscripts, manuscript 51,
page 25, 1899, 16 years before her
death. Quote, Satan will excite the
indignation of apostate Christrysendom.
That's those of us that reject the SDA
fanatic unbiblical theology.
Satan will excite the indignation of
apostate Christendom against the humble
the humble remnant. That's the SDA
church who conscientiously refused to
accept their customs and traditions
blinded by the prince of darkness.
Popular religionists will see only as he
sees and feel as he feels. They will
determine as he determines and oppress
as he oppressed. Liberty of conscience
which has cost this nation so great a
sacrifice will no longer be respected.
The church and the world will unite and
the world will lend to the church her
power to crush out the right of the
people to worship God according to his
word. Woo.
She continues
last day events. This is a compilation
book but still in the same topic the
same vein. Last day Events page 132.
quote, "Laws enforcing the observance of
Sunday as the Sabbath will bring about a
national apostasy from the principles of
republicanism upon which the government
has been founded. The religion of the
papacy will be accepted by the rulers
and the law of God will be made void."
Close quote. So all of us,
those of us that go to church on Sunday,
the universal church,
this is going to be us supposedly.
She continues, "Last day events, page
136.
The whole world is to be stirred with
enmity against Seventh Adventist. The
whole world,
everyone's going to be focused in on the
SDA supposedly
because they will not yield homage to
the papacy by honoring Sunday, the
institution of the anti-Christian
power."
Continues same page. quote, "The
so-called Christian world is to be the
theater of great and decisive actions.
Men in authority will enact laws
controlling the conscience after the
example of the papacy. Babylon will make
all nations drink of the wine of the
wrath of her fornication. Every nation
will be involved, the whole world.
There will be a universal bond of union,
one great harmony, a confederacy of
Satan's forces.
and shall give their power and strength
unto the beast. Inserts a little snippet
of scripture there. Thus is m manifested
the same arbitrary oppressive power
against religious liberty, freedom to
worship God according to the dictates of
conscience as was manifested by the
papacy when in the past it persecuted
those who dared to refuse to conform
with the religious rights and ceremonies
of Romanism.
She continues into page 147.
The persecutions of Protestants by
Romanism by which the religious or by
the uh by which the religion of Jesus
Christ was almost annihilated will be
more than rivaled when Protestantism and
popery are combined.
So, Protestants are going to link arms
with Roman Catholicism,
which will eventually link arms with the
whole world, and we're all going to be
united in one bond of union as a
confederacy of Satan's forces.
since Protestantism and Roman
Catholicism are both his working and we
are all going to supposedly rally up and
hunt down Seventh Day Adventists to have
them killed because they go to church on
Saturday.
Do not lump these people in with us. I'm
going to say this repeatedly tonight.
This is part of the reason why I started
answering Adventism because I need to
educate Catholics and Orthodox and all
these other traditions just as much as I
do evangelicals and Adventists. Do not
lump these people in with us. Do not
point to them. I hear Roman Catholics
sometimes point to this lowhanging fruit
to say, "See, that's the fruit of
Protestantism." No, it isn't.
Do not lump these people in with us. Do
not lump this organization in with us.
It is a separate thing.
It is a separate thing. They do not like
us just as much as they do not like you.
Do not lump them in with us.
But we're going to see how Satan sees
supposedly. We're going to see how he
sees. Feel how he feels. Determine how
he determines and oppress how he
oppresses.
The same movement that will cry foul
when you critique their theology. Just
look at the comments in my videos. the
amount of SDAs that think they're being
persecuted because their theology is
being critiqued, yet they attribute
murder to the hearts of Christians and
claim it's from God.
These are supposedly divinely inspired
statements from the throne room of God.
Give me a break. Give me a break.
Yet, the modern SDA wants to try and
buddy buddy up with you, Christian, and
act like we're brothers and sisters.
Understand this is what this
organization thinks about you. When the
charade is removed, the fake piety
extinguished, the theological fog is cut
through. This is what the SDA church
actually thinks about Christians.
Over and against the evangelicalistic
tactic of trying to act like we're
Christian family with the intent of
converting you.
Notice what she says here.
This is spiritual gifts volume one page
190.
quote, I saw I saw
that means it's coming from God, folks.
I saw that since Jesus had left the holy
place of the heavenly sanctuary and had
entered within the second veil. This is
the investigative judgment. The churches
were left as were the Jews. That's us.
And they've been filling up with every
unclean and hateful bird. I saw iniquity
and vileeness in their churches. Yet
they profess to be Christians. Their
profession, their prayers, and their
exhortations are an abomination in the
sight of God. Instead, the angel God
will not smell in their assemblies.
Selfishness, fraud, and deceit are
practiced by them without the reprovings
of conscience. And over all these evil
traits, they throw the cloak of
religion.
I was shown the pride of the nominal
churches. The irony.
God was not in their thoughts, but their
carnal minds dwell upon themselves. They
decorate their poor moral bodies,
talking about jewelry, and then look
upon themselves with satisfaction and
pleasure. Jesus and the angels looked
upon them in anger.
Said the angel, "Their sins and pride
have reached up unto heaven. Their
portion is prepared. Justice and
judgment have slumbered long, but will
soon awake. Vengeance is mine, and I
will repay, sayeth the Lord.
The fearful threatenings of the third
angel are to be realized, and they will
drink the wrath of God. An innumerable
host of evil angels are spreading
amongst them, spreading uh themselves
over the whole land.
The churches and religious bodies are
crowded with them, and they look unto
the religious bodies with exaltation,
for the cloak of religion covers the
greatest crimes and iniquity. Close
quote.
God supposedly showed her that he and
all of the angels are angry with
Protestants that rejected the silly 1844
message in the investigative judgment,
which again is Protestants, Catholics,
literally everyone except them.
Essentially, everyone who rejects their
message that bears the name of Christ. A
one-sizefits-all equal opportunity
offender kind of thing. the Christian
church universal, which we're going to
get into tonight.
And we're who is in focus when God says,
"Vengeance is mine. I will repay."
Notice, not the world, not those
professing, not not those not professing
Christ, the lost. Those of us who
profess Christ yet reject the SDA
church's false doctrine and message.
That's who the wrath of God is stored up
for. Our prayers are an abomination.
Evil angels have spread amongst us in
our churches.
This is why I do not take the bait when
they try and play the victim complex
game, folks. A common tactic with some
of them, don't take the bait. They love
to play the victim and act like they're
persecuted.
Give me a break. This movement is
definitionally an accuser of the
brethren, the the true Christian church.
And that's why my tone is changing
because I love the church. I love the
body of Christ. I love believers. I hate
false doctrine. And when people rise up
like this that start accusing Christ's
body, yeah, it offends me. It is
hardcoded into the movement's DNA.
The SDA church is an enemy of Christ in
his kingdom, and it needs to be
understood as such because they are
professional ste uh sheep stealers.
They are a professional sheep stealing
organization
and responding to talks like this one
will be we will be listening to tonight
from TED are a great teaching tool for
the body of Christ to really see what's
going on here. Now, I want to note this
message from TED was an internal
message,
meaning it was for those already in the
system that have the worldview hammered
into their mind already and understand a
number of buzz phrases and themes that
the average person listening isn't going
to know the specifics and nuances of.
So, we're going to be breaking those
down along the way. Now, he's going to
say a lot and we won't be able to
address it all exhaustively, but
remember these quotes as we listen.
Remember what we just read. Those are
thus sayeth the Lord's statements. Ted
is on record. We've responded in video
to where he says, "Don't shy away from
the spirit of prophecy." He exhorts,
he's speaking at the annual council,
which is two clergy in the SDA church.
And he says, "Be on the lookout for
people who are coming into your churches
who are downplaying the spirit of
prophecy," aka the writings of Ellen G.
White. He said, "Even the apocalyptic
hard to like accept passages or quotes
that she says like the ones we just
read, they uphold this. They believe
this. Don't give me this nonsense that
the SDA church does not uphold these
things."
remember those quotes tonight because
that's going to be foundational to the
whole thing tonight because you're going
to hear, "We just believe the Bible.
It's just the Bible." And you're going
to see what's actually going on there.
So, listen with that in view. And
remember the thesis. Why are there so
many denominations?
Why did Ellen say there were a ton of
denominations? Because they're a tool of
Satan. God's not behind any of it. And
it's a confusion tool. It's what Satan
is using to confuse people. But that's
the question he's seeking to answer for
the Seventh Day Adventist in this
internal message. So when I interact
with Adventists, you'll often hear me
use the term the script. Tonight you're
going to hear a lot of the script. It is
the standard fair SDA talking points
that aren't actually rooted in fact, but
in a worldview, namely the great
controversy worldview. So with that in
mind,
let's get started. here.
We are one family in Jesus Christ.
What a privilege to see all of you here.
Those of you in the balcony, thank you
for being here. Those of you here on the
main floor here in Indianapolis
in the Warren Performing Arts Center.
Indianapolis is a magnificent,
well-known city all over the world. In
fact, this weekend it is really well
known.
The Indie 500 will take place tomorrow.
Exciting events.
People are preparing.
But the good news is you are here today
preparing for an event even greater than
the Indie 500,
the coming of the Lord Jesus Christ.
All right. So notice right out of the
gate,
he starts off with the we are all one
family in Jesus Christ, referring
obviously to Adventists.
Adventists are that one family in
Christ. This is the setting of the stage
for the focal point of his talk. That's
what every SDA hears when they hear him
say this. They're not talking about the
pagan Sunday Christians. It's
Adventists. But right out of the gate,
belief and study of Seventh Day
Adventism is how one prepares for the
return of Christ. Notice that
you get the classic Adventist subtle dig
at people who enjoy things the SDA
church would call worldly, such as the
Indy500.
Real followers of Jesus will be sitting
in the Warren Performing Arts Center at
the Seventh Adventist General Session to
get further indoctrinated into the
system and be told lies about
Christians. That's how one is getting
truly prepared for the Christ return,
not by going to a car race. That's the
sort of thing that's going on here in
Adventism. Being born again, united to
Jesus Christ, having union with Christ
by virtue of his perfect work, holding
fast to him as the only anchor that can
weather the storm. Nope. That's not
enough to be prepared for the second
coming.
Adventists love to talk about how, oh,
we love the second coming. We're all
about the second coming. Yeah, it's
about more than just Christ's second
coming. It's that they think their
message is what prepares you for the
second coming. That's what Adventist
theology is supposedly for. It's to get
people prepared for the second coming of
Christ. And if you want to be ready, you
have to come drink from the well of
Adventist theology and fill yourself
full to really make sure that you're
ready.
This is why so many Adventists or or you
know Adventists and even former
Adventists aren't even excited about the
return of Christ but burdened, weighed
down, they feel inadequate, etc. But all
that to simply say this is him setting
the tone. Pretty standard tactic. Start
with a joke or a general statement to
drive your bigger point. In this case,
Ted is setting the stage for what he is
about to present.
and that it's believing what he's about
to present that will have someone ready
for the return of Christ supposedly.
Praise God for every one of you young
people, those of you in the balcony here
and those of you receiving this by live
streaming all over this globe. Coming to
you from Indianapolis in Indiana in the
United States. Pastor Finley had a
marvelous talk this morning
helping us to understand the final
events and the coming of Jesus Christ.
The understanding that his second
coming, Christ's second coming will not
be a quiet event. It will be an audible
event.
It will not be something which will be
unseen in a secret place. It will be
seen by every eye.
It will come with a shout, with a
proclamation,
with the trumpet of God.
What a wonderful introduction
to the topic that we're going to look at
right now, which is to help us
understand the leadup to this amazing
second coming of Jesus Christ.
Okay.
So in TED and the FDA church's eyes, the
reason they there are so many
denominations is because of Bible
prophecy, that is their pet obsession.
Bible prophecy supposedly reveals
that the reason there are multiple
denominations is tied to the second
advent of Christ. Think of this in light
of what Ellen G. White said earlier
regarding churches outside of themselves
being fallen, which was a fulfillment of
the first angel's message in 1844.
People rejected William Miller's
horrible hermeneutics and false date
setting. He was a false prophet.
His preaching of the imminent return of
Christ was predominantly rejected. And
according to Ellen White, God rejected
them because of it. So when Ted talks
about the second coming, understand he
is more specifically talking about the
imminent return of Christ, not just the
second coming generally speaking.
So all the denominations were rejected
by God that rejected their fanaticism.
And this plays into the idea for the SDA
church as to why there are so many
denominations.
Their movement wants to be all about the
second coming. So this is foundational
to their movement. Remember he said the
reason there are so many denominations
is a part of Bible prophecy. That's the
thesis of his talk tonight. It was
titled why are there so many
denominations?
God has rejected all these do
denominations including Roman
Catholicism, Orthodoxy, uh Assyrian
Church of the East, the Coptic Church,
the Marionite churches, the Syriak
churches, all of them
because they failed to listen to God's
messenger, Ellen G. White, who was
supposedly raised up, they love to say
like John the Baptist for the first
coming, only Ellen was the messenger
preparing the way before the second
coming. So that's what's going on here.
And since the imminent return of Christ
is a non-negotiable in Adventist
theology, meaning you can't believe the
return of Christ would be far into the
future. This is a gospel issue for them.
Now, he's going to break the ice on the
topic at hand. So, listen closely. The
topic for this hour
is one which a lot of people have
questions about. Why are there so many
denominations?
What is it that fractures us and doesn't
seem to pull us together?
I'll tell you right now, this precious
word, the written word representing
Jesus, the living word, pulls us
together because it contains all truth.
So this morning as we focus on this
subject, I want you to understand that
it will all come from the word of God.
You know, have you ever kind of wondered
if there's one God,
one Bible,
one Jesus,
why is it that there are so many
denominations, so many different groups
in the world? In fact, there are
thousands of different church groups
worldwide.
Indeed, an individual might be very
bewildered, confused
about why there are so many churches.
They don't really understand. One God,
one Bible, one Jesus, but thousands of
different churches. What is the answer
to this question?
Well,
a bigger question is which one of these
churches
is the right one?
Have you ever wondered, well, how can I
really truly find the truth? We know
from scripture that the Holy Spirit will
lead us into all truth.
So, why are there so many denominations?
Well, here's a secret.
You do not go to a church to find out
what truth is.
You go to the Bible,
to find out what truth is. Then you find
a church teaching in harmony with the
holy word of God.
So if you had to search the teachings of
every single church, you you'd probably
be looking through thousands of
denominations and different church
groups. That would take you a lifetime.
And in the end,
maybe you'd still be likely confused
about conflicting statements from
different churches. So never go to a
church to discover what is truth. You go
to the Bible.
All right. So get comfortable, folks,
because we're going to be camped out
here for a minute
because this sets the foundation for
where he's going to go in the talk. And
you want to have this information in
mind to filter through what he is
saying.
So, we get the standard SDA assertion
and false proposition that all
denominations supposedly view themselves
the way the SDA church does. You got to
understand this. Adventists think that
all denominations view themselves the
way Adventists view Adventism.
They think
all denominations think they're the one
true church and you have to try and find
the right one which is an impossible
laborous task that would just take a
lifetime.
And this is often said, as you'll see,
to bolster the idea that the SDA church
is one united monolith with no division,
strictly based on the Bible, showcasing
that they have the unity that Jesus said
his church would have. They keep the
commandments of God. Therefore, they're
the one true church.
And if you just read your Bible, you'll
see this is crystal clear and obvious.
Despite the fact that they make up
0.007%
of the world's population,
they're the only ones that actually
believe the Bible. Everyone else
doesn't. And that's supposedly why
they're divided and possess no unity.
They, you know, and they're um just
completely confused like Babylon. That's
the thinking and me messaging here. This
is simply not true. Okay,
let's start by defining our terms.
The word church, folks, has a semantic
range, meaning that depending on the
context that it's used in, it means
different things. TED is engaged in
what's called the fallacy of
equivocation,
and it scramles people's minds.
If you're not able to pick up on this,
it's when someone uses a word or phrase
in an argument to mean two or more
things, but doesn't clarify the
differences.
So Ted will use the word denomination
and call them churches when he says
there's all these different churches out
there. He means denominations when he
says that. But then he'll use the word
church that same way to try and say each
one thinks they are the true church.
the one true church.
In which case he would be referring to
the universal church, the body of
believers, the Catholic church. Sorry,
Adventists. That word just means
universal,
not Roman Catholic, but Catholic. Now, I
know that Roman Catholics are going to
want to latch on to that and say, "No,
no, no. That's not the focus for
tonight."
But Ted is not clarifying his
distinctions and equivocating the word
church by using it in two different ways
without distinction which is the root of
the whole issue.
Every church meaning denomination does
not think that they are the one true
church.
Now what do I mean by that?
There are three main ways that the word
church is used.
This is all three of them. Okay,
first you have the building.
Pretty self-explanatory. Local buildings
across the globe where various local
expressions of the one body gather to
conduct their worship services. There
are multiples of these obviously like
when someone says, "I'm going to church
tomorrow."
They're simply referring to the they're
using the term church to refer to the
location that they're going to be going
to gather with a local extension of the
body of Christ. So it can be said used
in that context which leads us to the
next usage the body
the eclelesia in Greek the calledout
ones.
So this refers to the universal church
both visible and invisible. I'll explain
what that is meaning in a moment.
This consists of the whole number of the
elect that have been are or shall be
gathered into one under Christ the head
of the body and apart from which there
is no salvation.
Whoops. Sorry.
This was set up by the Lord Jesus
Christ, not man. The building was
erected by a man. The denominations by a
man. The body was erected by the Lord
Jesus Christ.
It's all people both past, present, and
future who are united to Jesus Christ,
the head, in all places at all times.
This is the one holy church.
Rome, the East, etc. They're obviously
going to argue this definition with
classical Protestants. That's fine. Not
the discussion in view tonight.
This discussion is in the realm of
Protestantism and SDA claims and
assertions in light of that.
Now, this is not to be confused with
denominations.
There is only one body, not two, three,
four, etc. Only one.
People attached to Jesus Christ by faith
can be found in local Baptist churches,
Lutheran, Presbyterian, etc. They're all
all united to the same God by virtue of
the same gospel message, just like Paul
speaks about in Philippians 1:27-8.
What does he tell us there?
He wants to hear that they're standing
firm in one spirit with one mind,
striving side by side for the faith of
what?
The gospel.
That's what unites Christians. Same God,
same gospel. Baptists do not have a
unique gospel. Lutheran don't have a
unique gospel. The Dutch Reformed don't
have a unique gospel and so on. Real
world example. I can go out and do
street evangelism with Baptist and
non-denominational believers as I have
for years, laboring alongside one
another seamlessly for the same God and
his gospel. Our differences around how
we think the local church should be
governed has z literally zero bearing on
that.
Nowhere does scripture elevate such a
thing to be a dividing line. Nowhere
does scripture teach or present that if
you disagree on that you're wandering
after a false god or a false gospel.
We're on the same mission given by the
same Christ to take the same gospel to
the nations furthering the kingdom of
God. Period. same God, same gospel, same
mission.
But according to Ted, this shouldn't be
the case. I shouldn't be linked arms
with them because there's apparently no
unity there since I'm a Presbyterian.
That's the sort of messaging and
positioning put forth by Ted and the SDA
church. Yet, the reality is I'm far more
united with them than they are amongst
themselves.
Just go look at this past week's video
for Monday. Go look at the comments. You
have professing Adventists arguing back
and forth with each other on whether or
not the movement and Ellen White are
trinitarians.
They're not even united folks on who it
is that they worship.
Their local assemblies are filled with
people united on diet but not deity.
Yet this is the movement that is
completely in unity and everyone else is
Babylon confused silly pagans. Give me a
break.
The Adventist church is one of the most
theologically confused worlds I've ever
engaged in. And I've engaged with a lot
of people folks out on the streets.
Muslims, Mormons, Jehovah's Witnesses,
Haric Krishna's, PETA, the the the
animal rights group, atheists, Hindus,
the list goes on. And I'm telling you,
Seventh Day Adventism is one of the most
doctrinally divided movements I've ever
come across.
What unites them is their great
controversy worldview, meaning the way
they see the world and the day that they
go to church.
That is what unites 7th Adventists.
Anything beyond that is a complete
dumpster fire free-for-all.
It is theological anarchy. Bible and me
under the tree. I don't need no his
story type stuff.
And that's who Christians are supposed
to yield the creeds to.
We're supposed to believe Athanasius the
Great was a clueless heretic. Ignatius
was a pagan heretic. Ambrose Erynaeus
was a pagan heretic.
No. No. God wasn't leading these great
gifts to the Christian church in the
church's infancy as they stood against
actual idolattors and actual pagans. No.
No. Instead,
he was supposedly behind a 19th century
teenager who couldn't exeute her way out
of a wet paper bag and her
anti-trinitarian cohorts who the church
universally needs to be corrected by.
Yeah, give me a break.
This facade from the Adventist Church is
completely transparent. If you've ever
engaged with SDAs apologetically for
more than say two minutes,
the monolithic unity with everyone else
being Babylon full of division and
confusion is peak irony.
Peak irony. Pot meet kettle.
But finally, the third usage.
This is what Ted has been equivocating
between without distinguishing.
The second usage and the third are not
identical.
Denominations are human organizational
gatherings.
So I'll hear Roman Catholics for
example, sorry Roman Catholic friends,
I'm just using you as an example.
They'll mockingly ask me, "Don't you
realize, bro, that your church goes back
to the 16th century?" and they they're
making the same error.
That's because we don't believe only
Presbyterians or insert whatever
denomination make up the universal
church. Obviously, I know the history of
the Presbyterian denomination.
You're conflating denominational
organization with the universal church.
Denominations are simply visible local
expressions of extensions of Christ's
body where the word of God is preached.
The sacraments lawfully administered and
the triune God is worshiped with his
gospel being proclaimed.
The word of the true God is preached
which is the gospel to the ears.
It's believed in the heart and accepted
by the hearer. That action by a lawfully
commissioned bishop consecrates the
elements of bread, wine, and water to be
used for holy uses.
You repent of your sins before coming to
the Lord Jesus at his table to receive
the gospel to the eyes and the taste by
partaking of the Lord Jesus Christ
himself and receiving the benefits of
being united to him.
Again, this is not contained to one
single denomination like the SDA church
so wrongfully claims regarding
denominationalism.
And quite honestly, it's a similar
argument that Rome makes against
Protestantism. So to be fair, they
aren't alone in this by any stretch.
Ted, if you want to critique
Protestantism, then actually represent
it accurately,
as we're going to see momentarily, Ted's
surface analysis here is really nothing
more than rhetoric to rally up the echo
chamber.
So to take to to to showcase what I'm
saying here, let's look at a sampling of
what could be considered Protestant
confessions, actual source
documentation,
not Joe Schmo in the in the corner of
the internet somewhere,
actual statements of faith. Let's see
how divided they are from one another as
it pertains to who makes up the body of
Christ. Remember Ellen White said, "And
this is a thus sayeth the Lord.
They have no unity,
innumerable sex. They're all completely
divided and confused."
Let's look at these confessions. Do they
claim it's only themselves and no one
else? That's the true church. Do they
all claim to have a distinct mission and
message to take to the world that no one
else does, thus that they're they're
divided?
Is the mission the same across the
board, etc.? That's the sort of question
we're going to be asking.
So, first let's look at the historic
Presbyterian Confession. This is my
confession. This is what I align with
personally.
1646 Westminster Confession of Faith.
What's it say regarding the church?
Chapter 25 of the church. First point,
the Catholic or universal church which
is invisible and consists of the whole
number of the elect that have been are
or shall be gathered into one
under Christ the head thereof and is the
spouse the body the fullness of him that
fillth all in all. So the term invisible
is simply used to denote what we cannot
see which is people's hearts.
We can't see who's attached to Jesus
Christ, the head by faith. Only the
fruit of one's life and profession. This
is what James 2 is talking about, by the
way.
Two types of faith.
You can look at the fruit of somebody's
life and see that when they make a
profession based on not just what
they're claiming, but their actual
actions back up what they're saying.
That's all we can see.
So all of those that are united to Jesus
Christ by faith, that's who makes up the
one body of Christ. Again, those people
are all across the board. Sorry,
Adventist. Yep, some of them are in
Roman Catholicism, Eastern Orthodoxy,
etc.
But notice the framers of the confession
did not claim that everyone except
reformed believers are lost or everyone
that's not Presbyterian's lost.
It's simply that one has to be it's
simply that one has to be attached to
Jesus Christ the head.
Heck, John Calvin and his institutes, he
goes to great length to explain that the
individual Roman Catholic has to be
distinguished from the Roman institution
because true born again believers that
are attached uh attached to Jesus Christ
by faith are found in their midst.
He even defends the Eastern church. the
ve the very beginning of his of his
institutes in response to Rome's
anmatizing of them as schismatics and he
asks on what grounds because they dared
to question papal primacy.
So if you're an Adventist and try and
appeal to the reformers to support your
guys' stance, don't.
We do not have the same view as we're
going to see shortly.
despite all the Christian language they
try to use to make it appear as such.
But the confession continues.
The visible church which is also
Catholic or universal under the gospel
meaning it's not confined to one nation
as before like with Israel.
It consists of all those throughout the
world that profess the true religion and
of their children and is the kingdom of
the Lord Jesus Christ, the house of the
family of God, out of which there is no
ordinary possibility of salvation.
So the visible church is simply demote
uh uh denoting what can be seen with the
eye visible local expressions of
Christians gathering.
Amongst those bodies, you have a mix of
regenerate and unregenerate people.
Someone's not attached to Christ by
faith by virtue of simply attending a
local worship service. That's
essentially what's being said here. But
again, notice united to what? Or united
in what?
The gospel.
By virtue of which you have to be united
around the same God because it's his
gospel.
Presbyterians don't have their own
gospel unique to them.
That's why we can rightly recognize you
don't have to be a Presbyterian to be a
true Christian. You just need to be
attached to Jesus Christ by faith. And
apart from that, there is no salvation.
The idea of rogue Christianity, this
modern day idea, again, my Bible and me
under a tree, I don't need no history.
That type of stuff is totally foreign to
the the the Bible and Christian history.
because you commune with the Lord Jesus
corporately.
You commune with him as his body at the
appointed time to hear his word
preached, consecrating the the the the
elements and the sacraments, water,
bread, wine, setting aside those
ordinary means to then be used for holy
purposes.
After hearing the word preached, you
confess your sins and approach Jesus at
his table to commune with him and
partake of him.
That partaking of his body and blood is
the visible sign of all the promises one
receives by being united to Christ which
nourishes us, sanctifies us.
It is the gospel in essence being
applied to the eyes and the senses.
I love the Eucharist. I could sit here
and talk about this all night.
And again, that phrase Eucharist, folks,
is it just means thanksgiving.
But nevertheless,
that's why it then says,
"Unto this Catholic visible church,
Christ hath given the ministry, oracles,
and ordinances of God for the gathering
and perfecting of the saints in this
life to the end of the world, and doth
by his own presence and spirit,"
meaning he's present.
It's not just a memorial adventist.
according to his promise, make them
effectual there unto.
And again, I'm not going to spend all
night going in on sacramental theology
and whatnot. I could. I love this topic,
but I'm expounding slightly because as
we move to these other confessions, I
want you to see the unity that
supposedly doesn't exist according to
Ted Wilson and co.
But the sacraments were given to the
church, not each individual, such that I
can eat bread and wine alone and somehow
partake of Christ.
But then it says,
"Oh, sorry."
This Catholic Church hath been sometimes
more, sometimes less visible, and
particular churches which are members
thereof are more or less pure, according
as the doctrine of the gospel is taught
and embraced, ordinances administered,
and public worship performed more or
less purely in them.
The purest churches under heaven are
subject both to mixture and error, and
sometimes have so denigrated as to
become no churches of Christ, but
synagogues of Satan. Nevertheless, there
shall always
be a church on earth, capital C, to
worship God according to his will. So
notice
the claim isn't that the one true church
disappeared for centuries and needed
restored.
Don't appeal to that Adventist the
reformers to say, "Oh, well, we're just
like Protestantism." No, you're not.
But that one church universal can heir
because it's made up of humans.
Rome's going to argue with that.
Obviously, this goes back to the
arguments of the the Protestant
Reformation.
say a local church, uh, it's
non-denominational, let's say, they can
start off sound and allow damnable
heresy to creep in, embrace it, and no
longer be a valid local expression.
But that doesn't mean that the church,
capital C, has disappeared.
That local church has apostatized, but
not the one holy church.
There have been pe what this is saying
is that there have been periods of more
visible purity and times of less visible
purity. But the purity has still been
present on the earth since Jesus
established it.
The reformers argument with Rome was how
the term church or ecclesia is defined.
Not that the gates of hell ever
prevailed against the church. it was
totally lost and they needed revived so
that some people needed to rise up and
and take the torch and undergo such a
task.
Again, not to sidetrack into that
tonight, but just so it's understood
because I've heard I don't know how many
Adventists over the years that try and
ride the coattailes of the reformers and
claim we're just like them when it comes
to this. No, most certainly not.
So, that's Presbyterians.
Next up,
some people may not even consider
Baptist to be technically Protestant in
the historic and formal definition.
People often use it much too loosely to
Protestantism to refer to any group that
claims to be Christian but isn't
Catholic.
So, I'm using this tonight to show that
despite that, even their statement of
faith doesn't say what Ted is posturing.
What do they say about the church?
Quote,
"A New Testament church of the Lord
Jesus Christ is an autonomous local
congregation of baptized believers
associated by covenant in faith and
fellowship of the gospel."
In the faith and fellowship of what? The
gospel.
observing the two ordinances of Christ
governed by his laws, exercising the
gifts, rights, and privileges invested
in them by his word and seeking to
extend the gospel to the ends of the
earth. Each congregation operates under
the lordship of Christ through
democratic processes. In such a
congregation, each member is responsible
and accountable to the Lord Jesus
Christ.
Its two scriptural offices are that of
pastor and elder. and deacon or pastor,
elder and deacon.
While both men and women are gifted for
service in the church, the office of
pastor and elder is limited to men as
qualified by scripture.
The New Testament speaks also of the
church as the body of Christ, which
includes all of the redeemed of all the
ages, believers from every tribe and
tongue and people and nation.
close quote.
So here we see the exact same thing in
principle and foundation that the
Westminster confession said.
They simply added in that their church
governance differentiator into they they
included that into the statement that a
local New Testament church is an
autonomous local congregation.
But that differentiator from
Presbyterians doesn't make them idoltors
wandering after a false god and a false
gospel.
Again, a valid local church is one where
the word is preached, the gospel
heralded, which means include the
included the true God, and the
sacraments are lawfully administered.
What does it say that they're seeking to
do?
Advance the gospel to the ends of the
earth.
the exact mission Jesus left the
disciples with in Matthew 28. Take the
gospel to all nations, not some present
truth, distinctive special gospel
message that they supposedly got insight
into from the n from a 19th century
prophetist who butchered Revelation 14
to try and claim it's talking about some
end times special unique gospel message
that only they have to take to the
world. Now, the same gospel in view here
is the same gospel mentioned back in the
Westminster confession.
They state that the body of Christ is
all believers
in all times,
every tribe, tongue, people, and nation.
That's who makes up the one universal
body. Nothing about it being only
Baptists. nothing about it being united
with other uh uh not being united with
others who believe in and worship the
same God and believe his gospel.
And for all the Adventists who think
they can pin this on their favorite
boogeyman of Calvinism, this isn't a
Calvinist confession.
That's got nothing to do with what's in
view here. I'm as united with a Southern
Baptist on who God is and what the
gospel is and the mission of the
universal church to take that God and
gospel to the ends of the earth.
We've got the same foundation. We differ
on systematics.
And if you want to play the that's
ecumenical,
sure. I'm ecumenically united to any
person that is united to Christ by faith
as the universal Catholic church
catholic church. Sure.
Next up,
classical Anglican Confession, 1571 39
articles of religion. What do they say
regarding the church and our unity?
Quote,
the visible church of Christ is a
congregation of faithful men in which
the pure word of God is preached and the
sacraments are duly administered
according to Christ's ordinance. And all
those things that of necessity are
requisite to the same.
As the church of Jerusalem, Alexandria,
and Antioch have aired, so also the
church of Rome hath aired, not only in
their living and manner of ceremonies,
but also in matters of faith. Close
quote. Again, they say a valid visible
expression of the Christian church, the
one body, is one where the pure word is
preached. The sacraments are lawfully
administered and it's done by qualified
bishops.
Not that it's only Anglicans, and they
think they're only the one true church,
meaning they themselves are the
universal church in tot.
They affirm the same gospel, the same
God as the rest of us. Next up,
my Lutheran friends. Of course, I have
not forgotten y'all. 1520 Augsburg
confession. Classical Lutheran
confession of faith. What does it say?
This is from the book of Concord.
And they teach that only that that one
holy church is to continue forever.
The church is the congregation of saints
in which the gospel is rightly taught
and the sacraments are rightly
administered.
And to the true unity of the church,
okay, what do they talk about here
regarding unity? Remember Ellen White
said they have no unity these people.
And to the true unity of the church, it
is enough to agree concerning the
doctrine of the gospel and the
administration of the sacraments.
Nor is it necessary that human
traditions that is rights or ceremonies
instituted by men should be everywhere
alike. As Paul says, one faith, one
baptism, one God and father of all, etc.
Ephesians 4. Again, a valid visible
local church is one where the gospel is
rightly taught and the sacraments are
lawfully administered.
And where does it say that the unity of
the church universal lies? agreement
upon the gospel, who God is, the
administration of the sacraments.
And the Lutheran framers even tacked on
that tradition is not a dividing rule
for obvious reasons historically.
The gospel here is not any different
than we've seen mentioned in these
previous confessions. They are all
referring to the same message, the same
God who gave it, etc. They all agree on
what the church is, what makes a valid
visible extension of that body, etc.
Now, I could go on and on and on showing
more Protestant confessions.
say, compare the rest of the Anglican 39
articles to the Westminster Confession
of Faith, to the Congregational Seavoy
Declaration, to the 1689 London Baptist
Confession, to the Dutch Reformed Belgic
Confession.
Over 90% of the doctrine is essentially
identical.
Not even not just the chapters on the
church, the whole document.
So Ted is either one ill-informed which
is unacceptable for his level of
notoriety or two dishonest
because what he said previously is
historical revisionism and it's outright
false.
Mr. Wilson, I guarantee you guarantee
you
that we have more unity than you guys do
amongst your small world of Adventism.
Especially if we did our sampling per
capita.
These guys don't even realize, folks.
Born again Christians, they don't care
about denominations really. Like, it's
not that big of a deal. I was just
talking with a friend of mine about this
the other day. It's like, dude, we don't
care about that. I'm not trying to
convert my Baptist brothers to be
Presbyterians when I hang out with them
or do evangelism alongside them.
I mean, heck, there are people in my
local church who aren't even
Presbyterians
in terms of the formal sense. They
simply love Christ. They love the gospel
and want to worship and labor alongside
like-minded believers. They don't know a
lick about systematic theology. They're
just like standard fairs Christians that
love Jesus and serve him.
We're on the same page on the
fundamentals
and and being Presbyterian is irrelevant
at that level. There's something that
transcends that label.
There's been Roman Catholics I've been
standing outside the abortion clinic
with who we've talked and I'm like,
"Dude, I don't care about your label now
because I've asked you these questions
and at the end of the day,
I don't care about that. There's
something that transcends that. You
don't have that with Adventists.
We may differ on secondary doctrinal
matters, but we've got far far more
common, far more in common than we do
not.
But see, in Adventism, there is no such
thing as secondary doctrines.
Everything is a foundational dividing
line.
Yet we all Protestants affirm the
historic Christian creeds. We worship
the same God. We've got the same gospel.
We have the same mission to take that
God and his gospel to the world. We
worship together on the same day in
different locations commemorating the
same thing.
The new creation being inaugurated by
Jesus Christ by virtue of accomplishing
the work of redemption. ing from that
work and entering into his mediatorial
rest as our high priest king.
Doesn't matter if they're in Latin
America, France, Portugal, Baptist,
Moravian, non-denominational.
So, if you're coming out of Adventism
and you're struggling with this issue,
which I know that many are, do not take
the bait.
This whole thing is predicated on a
faulty premise that the SDA church has
to have in order for their system to
work. It is literally built on
equivocating church and using it in two
different ways without distinguishing to
try and paint the picture
that oh there's no unity amongst them.
They're completely divided.
But now I want to look at the SDA
church's fundamental beliefs in light of
all of that. So let's start with
fundamental belief number 12.
The church, what do they say? Quote,
the church is the community of believers
who confess Jesus Christ as Lord and
Savior.
In continuity with the people of God in
Old Testament times, we are called out
from the world and we join together for
worship, for fellowship and in or for
instruction in the in the word, for the
celebration of the Lord's supper, for
service to humanity, and for the
worldwide proclamation of the gospel. Oh
man, it sounds pretty good.
The church derives its authority from
Christ, who is the incarnate word
revealed in the scriptures. The church
is God's family adopted by him as
children. Its members live on the basis
of the new covenant.
So we get lots of Christianes here and
modeling of the wording based on
historic Protestant confessions.
Adventists love to to to point to this
vague general phrasing here and say,
"See, we're just like you guys, brother.
We believe the church is the community
of believers who confess Jesus Christ as
Lord and Savior. We don't believe it's
only us.
But once one parses through all of the
Christianes and you understand how
things are being defined like we're
going to look at, you'll see this isn't
what's being said.
Remember all those quotes we looked at
from their divinely inspired prophetus
earlier? Remember the SDA church upholds
those statements as from God himself and
completely in line with scripture. So
understand this statement in light of
those things that we looked at earlier.
So they start by defining the church as
those who are called out from the world
and quote we join together for worship.
Who's doing that with SDAs? They say we
referring to themselves.
Are they doing that when the rest of us
are are doing that? Of course not.
They don't consider our worship valid.
It's apostate, pagan, Roman Catholic in
origin, etc. So, do not be fooled.
They're not saying the same thing
regarding the universal church like like
we saw in those other confessions.
The church in Adventism is Adventism.
Period.
Just like the Protestant confessions,
they try to use the same barometer. the
preaching of the word, the Lord's supper
being administered, and the worldwide
proclamation of the gospel. So, see,
they're just like Protestants, right?
Except, folks, you know, if you've spent
any even a fraction of time on this
platform, you know what they mean by the
gospel. They're not heralding the same
gospel the Christian church is. They're
not meeting the same time we are. They
don't have the same mission we do.
They don't they don't mean the same
message that was in view in the
Westminster confession, the the 2000
Baptist faith and message, etc. They
mean their present truth only for a
special people at the end of the at the
end of time gospel
that they and only they are preaching
which by the way is a thrice cursed by
God message according to Galatians 1
6-12.
We looked at this last week for probably
the eenth time. If you haven't seen it,
go watch the video on present truth and
identity crisis.
While you're at it, go watch the Gospel
of Adventism playlist that we have on
our channel. Watch the open mics from a
couple weeks ago. We have gone over this
repeatedly and will continue to for
years to come.
This movement is simply leeching
Christian terms and using the same
language, but they mean something
totally different.
And then they'll try and saddle
Protestants with the same behavior.
They'll claim it's the exact same
wording as Protestant confessions, bro.
You're straining it now and nitpicking.
Except no, the Westminster confession,
Baptist faith and message, Augsburg,
etc., they mean the same thing when they
say the gospel. They're not talking
about various unique messages each
denomination has.
We're talking about the same gospel,
the one revealed by Jesus Christ to the
apostles that's been handed down to us
today to take to every tribe, nation,
tongue, and people.
The SDA church, on the other hand, has
completely redefined the words, which is
the problem. They're saying the right
words, but meaning something entirely
different.
They do this constantly
because everything for them is defined
by the means of the great controversy
theme. Another thing we've looked at
over and over and over again. Again, go
watch that Adventist Gospel playlist if
you haven't. I go into all the source
materials there.
But they do this constantly. Trinity,
Gospel, Solos Scriptor, Jesus, and so
on.
You have to scale the language barrier,
folks, if you're going to do apologetics
with the SDAs.
This movement is very good at
copyrighting and using all the same
lingo to appear like the rest of us. And
they are not.
They're not united with those of us who
worship on the first day
or those of us who are heralding the
true God and his gospel. They are
against them,
which we very clearly saw from Ellen
White earlier.
But then they continue,
quote, "The church is the body of
Christ, a community of faith of which
Christ himself is the head. The church
is the bride for whom Christ died that
he might sanctify and cleanse her.
At his return in triumph, he will
present her to himself a glorious
church, the faithful of all the ages."
Notice that, the faithful of all the
ages. We'll get back to that in a
moment. The purchase of his blood, not
having spot or wrinkle, but holy and
without blemish. Close quote.
Now, they're going to put more skin on
the bones in the next section. But take
notice here.
They tack in similar language regarding
the universality of the church, those
that are attached to Jesus Christ the
head. But as you're going to see
when we look past the surface level
presentable presentation of the
fundamental belief and actually go into
their explanation of it, something very
different is in view.
The faithful of of all the ages means
something very specific and it plays
into the whole narrative that the
universal church went completely
apostate after the time of the apostles
and the true church was this small
virtually unknown group of people that
one can hardly find anything about in
history that was supposedly upholding
the seventh day Sabbath and all this
sort of stuff. That's what's ultimately
going on here as you're going to see
because what's connected to this belief
is number 13 which is the remnant and
its mission.
Quote, "The universal church is composed
of all who truly believe in Christ."
Again, folks, this is just the
fundamental belief on the surface. On
their website, you're going to see you
can click into each belief and they
expound upon it, which is what we're
going to do. So this is SDAs love to
point to this and say, "See, you're
you're he's making stuff up. He's a
liar. They don't know what they're
talking about." yada yada.
The universal church is composed of all
who truly believe in Christ. But in the
last days, a time of widespread
apostasy.
A remnant has been called out to keep
the commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus.
Using the wording of the King James
rendering there specifically of
Revelation 12,
this remnant announces the arrival of
the judgment hour, aka the investigative
judgment, proclaims salvation through
Christ, aka the sanctuary doctrine, and
heralds the approach of his second
advent. Ah, just like like Ted mentioned
earlier, remember all of Adventism has
to do with being prepared for the second
advent, which is their three angels
gospel message, which is what they say
here next. This proclamation is
symbolized by the three angels of
Revelation 14. It coincides with the
work of judgment in heaven and results
in a work of repentance and reform on
earth. Every believer is called to have
a personal part in this worldwide
witness. Close quote. Ah,
so the universal church is indeed
composed of all of those who truly
believe in Christ. But remember, I've
said this before, everyone loves a good
butt.
In these last days, there is widespread
apostasy. So the true church is a
remnant of people called out from all
that. Aka the universal church is
Babylon.
The remnant, the true church is the
SDAs.
They are the ones supposedly keeping all
the commandments of God in accordance
with Revelation 12. They have the
writings of LG White, which is
supposedly the spirit of prophecy.
So therefore, they're what the Bible is
talking about.
Now, there are so many erroneous
assumptions regarding that, and if we
were to address all of it, we would be
here all night.
The reading of themselves into a book
that was written in the first century to
an audience of that time that didn't
have chapter and verse divisions,
what we call chapter 14 or chapter 12,
that actually had no application to that
generation, that time.
No, no, no.
It's about some people far off into the
future, the seventh day aventus.
No. It's not about some special group of
people that so badly want to read
themselves into the Bible nearly 2,000
years into the future that arbitrarily
through wonky exesus and mental
gymnastics try and make 1844 some giant
turning point of the end times.
Read Hebrews 1, folks. Adventist, you
love going to Acts, you know, Acts where
where Peter quotes Joel. Ironically
enough, that's where I'm at with with my
family and family worship. I thought
about this. It was actually today this
morning.
You always want to jump there and say,
"See, it's talking about the last days."
And go to Hebrews 1. There's there's
more places that the same the same thing
is referenced. The last days was here
long before 1844.
First few verses of Hebrews 1. Notice
how the author uses the phrase the last
days. And when he applies it, I'll give
you a hint. It is not 1844. That's for
sure.
But back to the fundamental belief.
This is now where their unique gospel
message is woven into the frame.
So when they say worldwide gospel
proclamation back in belief 12, this is
what they mean. their third their their
three angels gospel message that they
claim is all found, you know, in
Revelation 14:6-12.
It's a present truth message that no one
else in history proclaimed. Not the
apostles, not the church fathers, not
the reformers, not the medieval fathers.
Nope. Only them.
They state this repeatedly in their own
publications, as we've shown over and
over and over again.
They say every believer is called to
take part in this worldwide witness.
Aka, it's only our church that's
spreading this message around. So by
believer, what they actually mean is
seventh adventist. That's who a true
believer is.
See what I'm saying? My never been
seventh adventist listener.
Even the term believer here implies
seventh adventist. Not Baptist, not
Presbyterian, not Lutheran.
No,
they aren't heralding this supposed or
they're heralding the supposed end times
gospel message and Baptists, Lutheran,
Presbyterians, they're not heralding
that.
Now, like I mentioned earlier, once you
get past the service level presentation
of the blurb that is the fundamental
belief on their website, you can click
into each one and see a fuller
explanation, which is essentially a
summary of each belief with much of the
information pulled from their 7th Day
Adventist believe 28 fundamental beliefs
book, which I have back on the shelf
right there.
So, let's keep fleshing this out, shall
we? Under belief number 12, under the
heading titled What the Church will be
like near the end times,
it says this.
As the world descends into turmoil, as
things get closer to the second coming
of Christ, the church will be God's
faithful people who hold on to his
teachings.
That is a key. Even while the rest of
the world distances themselves from God,
those in God's church remain faithful to
him. They will hold out as holy among
the wickedness of the world. Then they
quote Revelation 14:4. It's those who
follow the lamb wherever he goes. These
have been redeemed for mankind as first
fruits for God and the lamb. We are told
that Jesus will present the church uh
the church to himself in splendor.
Ephesians 5:27. When he returns to
earth, close quote.
So they claim the church will be God's
faithful people who hold on to his
teachings. Again, on the surface, most
Christians will hear this and think,
"Yeah, I agree."
Except what they mean is, like I
mentioned earlier, the true church is a
small pocket of virtually unheard people
down through the ages who believe the
7th day Sabbath like the Adventists.
Because if you don't agree with their
butchering of the fourth commandment and
Judaizing, you're not faithful to God's
teachings. Thus, you're not a part of
the church.
They love to try and appeal to the
Waldenzians, for example, to try and
point to someone in history that looked
like them.
That's because this is what Ellen White
so erroneously asserted in the great
controversy,
which the White Estate even had to
admit. And they quietly they quietly
added a note about it in the appendex,
which essentially says, well, when they
used the term Sabbath, they didn't mean
the seventh day Sabbath. But
we do have some accounts of them
worshiping with some Jews periodically.
So that's good enough.
Go look at it for yourself, folks. Go to
the chapter of the great controversy on
the Waldenzians.
Look at it. They added that. That's
what's in the notes.
Well, we know that.
Yeah. Yeah. Trying to appeal to my
spiritual ancestors. We have an article
breaking all this down on our website,
by the way, for those that are curious.
Just type in Waldenzians into the search
bar up top and it'll pop up. No
Adventists. The Waldenzians always were
and still are Calvinists.
They uphold the 1559 Hugenotic
confession. It's a Presbyterian
Calvinist confession. It never ceases to
amaze me. For those that do not know,
the SDA church loathes Calvinism. I
mean, absolutely despises it.
Yet, when they need a favor from
history, they don't mind writing the
coattales of those that they loathe to
try and bolster their narrative. They do
this with Roman Catholicism, too.
Anytime Rome says something that the SDA
church thinks helps their case, they're
all about it. See, Rome even agrees they
changed the Sabbath.
Except no, Mr. or Mrs. Adventist.
They're not saying what you guys claim.
you're committing word association
fallacy. Rome will be talking about
apostolic succession and that the
apostles the apostles instituted worship
on Sunday. Then they'll say Protestants
have no basis for worshiping on Sunday
because they don't go back to the
apostles because Rome claims that the
apostles were Roman Catholics. So if you
break away from them, you have no basis
for worshiping on Sunday because the
apostles made that change and you're no
longer attached to them. Make sense?
They believe Roman Catholics
that the apostles were Roman were the
first Roman Catholics. And so they
believe that the apostles were the ones
that instituted worshiping on the first
day. So if you break away from Roman
Catholicism, therefore you're not
attached to the apostles and you have no
basis to worship on the first day.
That's the claim. That's what's going on
in these statements that the SDA church
loves to try and point to to say, "See,
they even admit what we teach." Except
again, no, Mr. and Mrs. Adventist.
They aren't saying hundreds of years
after the apostles, the papacy rose up
usurping the law of God and yada yada
yada.
But all that to say,
what the SDA church means by the church
is themselves.
They are the ones supposedly faithful to
God because they keep his commandments,
which really just means I go to church
on Saturday.
Everyone else is supposedly in
disobedience, rebelling against God, is
lost. That's what they teach.
Anyone saved outside of their band is
saved in ignorance.
It's because they're ignorant of the
truth that the SDA church has, but God's
only going to judge them based on the
light that they currently have.
So that's how they're going to try and
weasle around the fact that they do
indeed teach that they alone are the
true church.
Now under fundamental belief number 13
when you click under the the the
fundamental belief itself on their site
under a heading titled the end times
remnant and who will be a part of it.
Notice, quote,
"Those who are part of this remnant are
recognizable by the way they choose to
obey God's commandments at all costs,
pledging themselves their allegiance to
him and turning away from sin." The
Apostle John, the last of Jesus's
disciples and the one who wrote
Revelation, tells us exactly who Satan
will target.
Satan's goal is to harm those who keep
the commandments and believe what Jesus
taught. But among the lawlessness of the
corrupt world, God will call for his
devoted followers to separate themselves
from those who have rejected him. Close
quote.
So the remnant are those who choose to
obey God's commandments, aka go to
church on Saturday,
even though that isn't actually enough.
You have to have the three angels
messages, the spirit of prophecy
contained in Ellen White's writings like
we saw with Dr. O a number of months
ago. But nevertheless, you disagree with
the SDA church's faulty understanding of
the Sabbath, you're not part of the true
people of God. Doesn't matter how much
scriptural evidence you can point to to
the contrary. Ellen White said it.
That's precious light from the throne
room of God. Her inter- her
interpretations of scripture stand. And
that's that.
Then we get a glimpse into the SDA
victim complex and where it stems from.
It's stuff like this.
When Revelation talks about the devil
making war with the woman, that's
obviously the Seventh Adventist Church.
Again, reading themselves into the
Bible, never mind the first century
audience Revelation was written to. No,
no, that's irrelevant to them. John was
talking about 7th Day Adventism and
October 22nd, 1844, which was supposedly
the turning point into the last days
where the gospel, you know,
arbitrarily beca, you know, the gospel
at that point arbitrarily became the
last day present truth message that a
bunch of fanatics coming out of one
fanatical movement after the next were
given by God through a 19-year-old who
had mental health complications due to
being hit in the head with a rock at 9
years old.
That's totally what John was referring
to.
Satan is supposedly focused in on the
SDA church because they go to church on
Saturday. Remember the stream from a few
weeks ago for those that saw it
responding to Mark Finley on the Sabbath
and why Christians go to church on the
first day
where he kept imagining
which was actually him paraphrasing
Ellen White literally like almost
verbatim.
my I see in my imagination. No, you
don't. You're literally just
regurgitating Ellen White's writings as
we showed Spirit of Prophecy Volume 4.
But she claimed that Satan held a
diabolical council meeting in the back
alley of outer space somewhere to figure
out his with his minions how he could
attack Seventh Day Adventist for going
to church on Saturday. True story. Go
check it out. That's what she says and
that's how Mark Finley says it. He says,
"In my imagination,
I see Satan holding a diabolical council
in outer space."
What?
We just believe the Bible. Yeah. Okay.
But here we see yet again more of this
fear-mongering and scripture twisting.
Satan persecuting the woman has nothing
to do with the Seventh Adventist Church.
They don't keep the commandments.
They're idoltors. They have a false god
and a false cursed gospel. Period. End
of story. Give me a break.
Don't keep the commandments. You guys
violate the second commandment more than
almost anyone I've seen other than the
Mormons.
You're constantly making images of a
person of the Godhead. Give me a break.
They also mention that God's calling his
people to separate themselves from those
who have rejected him. To really
understand the fullness of this,
remember the Ellen White quotes from
earlier.
Part of the SDA church's call is to come
out of Protestantism into Adventism.
You're in Babylon and need to leave and
join them or you're going to get the
wrath of God poured out on you.
Those in Protestantism have supposedly
rejected the SDA gospel and teachings.
So, God has rejected them, which is what
Ellen White claimed.
So, they're calling you, whoever you
are, to leave and join them, the true
church.
If you don't do this, well, you just
aren't a true follower of Christ. You
love your sin. You disparage the idea of
obedience, that sort of thing. Because
God's true people will supposedly hear
the Adventist message, see the truth of
it, and come join them.
We see this very clearly in the next
paragraph where it says, "Then I heard
another voice from heaven saying,"Come
out of," talking about Babylon, "my
people,
lest you take part of her sins, lest you
share in her plagues, for her sins are
heaped high as heaven, and God has
remembered their iniquities."
Those who did not come out of the
wickedness of the word, which that's a
spell issue on their website. I just
typed it as it is. I'm pretty sure they
mean world. Those
who do not come out of the wickedness of
the world will be subject to the same
fate as Satan. Utter destruction.
Utter destruction.
God refuses to let sin go on forever.
And those who hold on to sin will have
to account for their deeds. 2
Corinthians 5:10. Again, people are
going to hear this and say, "Well, of
course, any person that holds on to
their sins." Right. Right. Right.
But God's remnant people are not
supposed to just hide in holes as they
separate themselves from the world. God
has a job for who?
His people to do a message they will
deliver. For many people
this message will make the difference
between eternal life with God and the
permanent second death. All who hear it,
this is the Adventist message, folks,
will have to make a single vital
decision. Either to follow God or side
with Satan and share his fate. Close
quote.
Sorry, I forgot to click over to the the
last part there.
So, if you hear the Adventist me,
you have an option. You have a choice to
make. either accept it or you're going
to be completely lost. But those that
don't hear it, of course there'll be
people that are saved that aren't
Adventists. This is what they mean.
They they they're saved in ignorance.
It's cuz if they were part of this
present truth time, meaning they lived
post 1844 to the second coming. If they
heard the message, they'll be
accountable for rejecting it and be
lost. But if they never heard it, well,
they can still be saved in ignorance.
Remember
how Ellen White defined Babylon?
Catholic and Protestant churches.
Sorry, church in the east, Coptic,
theak, Marionite churches. You guys get
to miss out on the fun.
But they cite that verse of Revelation
bringing with it all their assumptions
as if no one else before them knew about
this verse or understood it and claim if
you don't come out of that that
wickedness,
you'll be the you'll be a subject of the
same fate as Satan. Utter destruction.
And God has a job for who? His people.
Who are his people?
The Seventh Day Adventists
with their three angels gospel. That's
the message God supposedly has for his
people, the Adventist God. Anyways,
and they say that this message will make
a difference between eternal life and
damnation for some people. Any person
who hears it will have to make a vital
decision. Follow God, aka accept their
message, despite it being absurdly
false, or you're siding with Satan.
Remember a few weeks ago during the open
mics for those that those of you that
saw it, one of the SDAs that called is
asked or the one of the SDAs that called
in asked, "Wait, you think we teach if
you don't believe these doctrines,
you'll be lost?" He asked that to a
slide that I had up that listed out the
pillar doctrines of the Adventist
gospel.
He wanted the wanted to act like the SDA
church doesn't teach that. Here you go,
friend.
Your movement states this over and over
and over all over the place. Your
prophetus,
that's who the movement's getting its
marching orders from, is found saying
over and over and over again the same
thing.
Don't act like I'm making things up out
of thin air. I'm just a mocker and a
scoffer, etc. It's right there. Yes, you
guys teach that your novel gospel became
the gospel that people are now
accountable to in 1844.
If a person hears it, rejects it,
they'll be lost.
Salvation only exists for those who die
in ignorance of this present truth
message during this present truth time
because every generation supposedly had
their own present truth they're
accountable to. All various gospels
throughout history, different gospels,
total theological dumpster fire.
So Adventist, please do not give us this
nonsense that you guys are just another
Protestant denomination. Be honest. Stop
playing word games and trying to buddy
buddy up with us. We are not brothers
and sisters in Christ. I would love to
be. I would love to be.
But if you're holding to the teachings
of this movement, nope. There is a wall
up. You're not my enemy, but you're not
my brother or sister.
And the word games are old. Own up to
your belief. Stop trying to play both
sides.
You guys think that we are in grave
danger. We think you're in grave danger.
One side is willing to own it. Me. The
other wants to play ring around the
rosie and dance around the facts.
Own it. so that we can have an honest
dialogue and not waste 45 minutes going
around in circles where you try and play
the we're just like you, brother. No,
not gonna happen. So, I know that was a
lot. I gave you a fair warning
that we were going to be camped out here
for a bit, but the rest of what Ted is
going to say needs to be understood with
all of that in mind.
So, one, the church is not a bunch of
divided, non-unified, confused people
who all have different gospel messages,
and you have to try and find the right
one.
That's not at all what's going on
regarding denominationalism.
Maybe sometime we will do a stream
specifically dedicated to the history of
denominationalism and dive even further
on that. But nevertheless,
Ted and the SDA church are wrong to
claim this,
especially considering they are the ones
rife with division and arguing at the
most basic level.
The Adventist church too defines
themselves as the true church and
everyone else is apostate. Even if they
want to try and play word games and
dance around the fact, it is hardcoded
into the system. They are definitionally
accusers of the brethren.
I just had a lady commenting on my video
videos yesterday. You can always tell
the person who's new that ends up on the
channel. I always say, you know,
welcome. Thanks for being here. But you
can always tell because they go on a
spree. You know, you you get like 15
notifications from them where it's like,
okay, clearly you just found the
channel. She said, "It's very telling.
The SDA church never attacks other
churches like this guy does. Give me a
break. Give me a break. What are you
talking about? It's literally hardcoded
into the system." Yet, you turn it
inward and all of a sudden, oh, we're
victims. Whoa, we're persecuted. No,
you're not. Your theology is being
critiqued.
If that's how persecution is defined,
you guys are the biggest persecutor of
Christians in the world.
literally hardcoded into the system.
Don't give me that. But then three, the
the third point with all that, they very
clearly believe the unique message they
possess is the mission God has for his
people, aka them, to take to the rest of
the world. So when their fundamental
belief number 12 says the church is
united in taking the gospel to the
world, they mean the SDA church is
united in taking their novel message to
the rest of the world because they
believe they are God's true people. So
remember all of that in going forward. I
know we haven't listened to a lot yet,
but that's because we're setting the
stage here for you to understand what
he's going to say moving forward
because he's going to be using just
general terms. But understand what he is
defining these things as is in
accordance with the SDA church, which is
ultimately defining it based on Ellen
White's commentary. His whole talk is
predicated upon this erroneous
assumption and claim regarding
denominations. Yet, it's not even true.
Not in the slightest.
Mercy. We're only 5 minutes in and the
rest of the sections.
The rest of the sections, folks, will
not be as long as this. But again,
laying that out was pertinent. So, with
that said, let's continue.
Now, you'll recall we have used this
before. I'd like you, in fact, you
sounded really good. Pastor Finley got
you involved in reading right from the
screen. I'd like you to read this with
me. All right, let's begin. If it's in
the Bible, I believe it. If it disagrees
with the Bible, it's not for me.
So, the Bible is central in all that we
must discover.
Bible prophecy clearly reveals why there
are so many denominations. God has
particularly revealed the answer to our
question about why so many denominations
in the book of Revelation. It shares
that with us. You see, God has revealed
the history of Christianity more clearly
than in any other place in Revelation 6.
Okay?
So notice,
no one believes what they do because of
scripture.
We don't believe what we do because of
only the Adventists.
And this sort of thinking
permeates the Adventist worldview.
Again, they put out this facade that
they're completely united. They agree on
scripture across the board. Unlike those
confused, unbiblical, tradition
following Protestants who have no basis
for their beliefs. This sort of thing.
That's what's going on here. What what
Ted really means by this is our inter
what he really means by all this is that
our interpretation of the Bible is
infallible. Therefore, everything we
believe is biblical.
Let's use the cursed three angels gospel
for example.
You'll ask them to show it to you from
the Bible and they'll literally just
read Revelation 146 through2 thinking
that somehow proves anything.
Those six verses supposedly tell you the
first angel's message had to do with the
year 1844 and people listening to
William Miller and then the
investigative judgment starting which is
a judgment only for professing believers
all the way back to Adam where the ten
commandments are the standard by which
every person will be judged to see
whether or not they've arrived at a
state of sinlessness
and if they haven't they'll be lost etc.
All of that is supposedly present in the
phrase, "Behold, the hour of his
judgment has come."
Again, completely ignoring this was
written almost 2,000 years ago.
Has nothing to do with 1844.
Had application to people long before
then.
The phrase come out of Babylon is just
obviously talking about Protestants
needing to lead their church and come
join the remnant because Ellen White
claimed Babylon meant what they believe
and she was receiving it from God
himself. End of story.
That's what Ted actually means by their
system is biblical.
They can point the little proof text
here and there, insert a bunch of stuff
into it, and that makes it biblical.
Here's an experiment for you, Christian.
Try the same thing with them.
Tell them that they don't actually
believe the Bible. Choose what doctrine
you want to highlight. Then simply cite
a couple verses and say, "See, that's
what the Bible says. So if you disagree
with me, you're a tool of Satan. You're
deceived. And if you reject my
interpretation, your fate will be that
of Satan's."
See how well the Adventists will yield
to that practice? I'm guaranteeing you.
I guarantee you they'll argue and say,
"No, your interpretation's flawed.
Here's why."
And then they'll seek to expound upon
the verse.
But now, when it comes to their system,
nope.
You disagree with their interpretation,
you're disagreeing with God's messenger,
LG. White, and she sheds light onto the
greater light, meaning she's the
infallible interpreter.
What she says goes. She corrects
inaccurate interpretations of scripture.
That's what their statement of
confidence in her writing states. And
stick around to the end if you're an
Adventist because we're going to show
primary source documentation
that says this exact same thing beyond
just the statement of confidence in her
writings.
It is the neverending double standard of
Seventh Day Adventism.
But understand that is what Ted means by
if it's in the Bible, it's for me. and
that everything he's going to present
will be strictly from the Bible. That's
what he means. He'll simply cite proof
texts, make assertions, assume his
adventist worldview, and then marvel at
how biblical Adventist theology is.
And of course, Revelation supposedly
tells us why why there's a variety of
denominations.
Adventist theology, like every
apocalyptic group, is fundamentally
built on the apocalyptic books of
scripture.
Not the plain clear didactic parts, but
the symbolic easy to twist and bend to
make fit with your narrative parts.
So, Revelation supposedly tells us why
there are so many denominations. That's
what John had in mind, right?
Because again, Revelation's focus is
post 1844, silly Christian. Didn't you
know that?
Now, let's hear how John the Apostle
supposedly was prophesying about
different denominations.
He's revealed the history of
Christianity from the first century in
the days of Christ right down to the
21st century in when in which we find
ourselves right now. And he's revealed
how Christianity would begin as one
movement, one body, and then would break
into varying
denominations.
He explains why those denominations
would emerge.
And this is one of the most fascinating,
one of the most exciting prophecies in
the entire holy word. Revelation chapter
6. So here we have Revelation's four
horsemen. They represent four successive
ages in the history of the church.
Now, the author of this prophecy,
the one that opens the seals of this
prophecy
is Jesus Christ himself. Revelation 6
and verse one. Let's look at it. Now, I
saw when the lamb opened one of the
seals. Now, who is who is this? All
right. Jesus the lamb of revelation.
So Jesus gives us now the history of
Christianity.
Now Revelation 6 continues and it says,
"And I heard one of the four living
creatures saying with a voice like
thunder,
come and see."
Verse two. And I looked and behold
a white horse. Now remember previously
just in the last phrase it says this
voice was like thunder. Come and see.
This is something God wants you to
understand today.
A white horse. He who sat on it had a
bow and a crown was given to him and he
went out conquering
and to conquer.
Pastor Finley mentioned this particular
horse and the rider this morning in his
presentation. You see, there are four
horses that gallop across the sky. one
right after the other. But when Jesus
opens these seals, he shows church
history in phases.
The first period is represented by a
white horse.
As Pastor Finley mentioned,
white is a symbol of purity. And the one
riding that horse wearing a crown is
Jesus himself. He goes out conquering
and to conquer. Now the first phase of
the Christian church is pictured as a
rider on a white horse triumphing and
conquering
all the forces of evil. And that's what
that horse in this beautiful panel
represents over to your right side as
you look at it. The white horse
represents a powerful
pure faith. In the New Testament, God's
truth triumphed
from AD 31
after the death of Christ to AD 100. The
disciples preached the truth of God's
word powerfully through the power of the
Holy Spirit. One Roman writer wrote the
following. It's an amazing statement.
You Christians are everywhere. You are
in our armies, in our navies. You are in
the marketplace and the shops. You are
in our Senate and universities. You are
everywhere.
You see, the New Testament church grew
very rapidly. Nothing could stop the
progress of Christianity in the first
century.
Like a white horse, victorious,
this white horse is conquering and
pushing and moving forward. And the
Christian church galloped across the
sky. The power of the gospel could not
be stopped.
All right.
So, one of the most fascinating
prophecies in all of scripture
is that there would eventually be
denominations
in all of scripture.
Because the churches that John was
writing to that were under severe
persecution totally gave a rip about
that, right? That's totally what they
needed to hear amidst why John's writing
them.
That had some sort of pertinent
importance to them in their great time
of need.
How absurd.
No, the most fascinating prophecies in
scriptures are those that pointed to
Yahweh himself actually coming and
dwelling among us.
Yes, Adventists, there's prophecy that
doesn't just deal with esquetology.
the incarnation, the bridging of the gap
between God and man forever by way of
the suffering servant that then inherits
all the earth as a man and takes total
dominion over it just like he said he
would hundreds of years before doing so.
Or maybe the psalter that said that the
perfect Passover lamb would come and
none of his bones would be broken,
which is exactly what happened.
But no, no denominations.
That's far more fascinating
because then they get to weasel in the
SDA church into the narrative.
But he said the history of the of
Christianity is revealed in more depth
than any other place in all of scripture
in the book of Revelation.
I I just have to say that I'm laughing
not at them, but because it's just such
an Adventist thing to say.
If you've come from that world, it's
like it's just such an Adventist thing
to say that. Because
of course, Revelation is their answer to
the question.
If I were a betting man, which I'm not,
my money would 10 out of 10 go on Daniel
and Revelation.
But hold up, Ted.
You guys were saying the same thing in
the 19th century
that Revelation 6 lays out history from
the first century down to the 19th
century.
But as time goes on, you guys just tack
on another century.
This is why I always say that the clock
is the biggest enemy of the SDA church.
And there's literally nothing they can
do to beat it
because God owns the clock.
Adventism will literally be one of
Christ's easiest enemies to defeat and
put under his feet because all he has to
do is what he's been doing for 2,000
years.
But Ted says that they believe the four
horsemen in Revelation 6 are four
successive ages in the Christian
church's history personified.
Meaning the rider on the horse is a
personal figure that represents
an age of the Christian church.
But he assumes here they know with 100%
certainty what every sign, symbol, and
number means without question. In this
case, it's the white horse and all the
imagery surrounding it. The bow, the
rider, the color white, and so on.
He said, "Revelation 6 lays out the
history of the Christian church from the
first century down to the 21st century."
Ted is just paring here Uriah Smith's
book for those that do not know, Daniel
and Revelation, which is his commentary
on both,
which is ultimately informed by Ellen
White. And they all pair with this
We're not going to be able to tackle
this in tot.
So maybe we'll do that at a later point.
But that's what Smith said.
Anti-trinitarian alert, folks.
Anti-trinitarian heretic alert.
Notice what he says.
Quote, "The first symbol, a white
horse." This is him commenting
Revelation 6. And the writer who bears
the bow to and to whom the crown is
given and who goes forth conquering and
to conquer is a fit emblem of the
triumphs of the gospel in the first
century of this dispensation. When he
says gospel there folks, that is not to
be confused with the quote unquote
everlasting gospel.
This is what Herbert Douglas calls a
limited gospel. The gospel is just a
limited gospel. It's not the everlasting
gospel.
He continues, "The whiteness of the
horse denotes the purity of faith in
that age. And the crown which was given
to the rider and his going forth
conquering and to make still further
conquest, the zeal and success success
with which the truth has promagated by
its earliest ministers."
To this it is objected by the ministers
of Christ and the progress of the gospel
could not be properly represented by
such warlike symbols.
But we ask
by what symbols could the work of
Christianity better be represented when
it went forth as an aggressive principle
against the huge systems of the error
with which it had to first contend.
The rider upon this horse went forth
where his commission was unlimited. The
gospel, again, the limited gospel was to
all of the world. Close quote. So again,
I just want to emphasize this is not to
be confused with the SDA church's
everlasting gospel.
The apostles gospel was a present truth
message for them.
That might be the contention with some
people that the gospel wouldn't be
described using warlike symbols,
but that most certainly isn't going to
be my contention or the contention of
many others. And I'm not unique in my
view, which is why I say that.
But what I most want to highlight is
that they have to have their assertions
on this be correct to validate
Adventism.
I want to emphasize that
unlike Christians, our entire system and
validation is not built on esquetology
like theirs is.
They are so convinced they have it all
figured out. They're masters of Daniel
and Revelation.
So much so that their entire movement
and foundation is staked on every single
chain in the link which is hundreds of
links being correct.
If even one breaks their whole system
falls.
That is how foundational esquetology is
to their system.
But that is what Ted is paring here.
This is what they're using in Adventist
universities in their religion
department.
Shoot, they teach an entire Daniel and
Revelation class with this. This is the
hardware that Ted was equipped with
decades ago, I'm sure.
So, he says the white horse represents a
pure church and that Revelation 6 shows
how Christianity would start as one
unified movement and then splinter into
various denominations.
totally absurd.
Again, with his equivocating the body of
Christ with individual denominations,
he's using the word church for both, but
then not differentiating between the
differences.
But second off, Ted, Revelation 6 has
nothing to do with denominations.
This is a horribly anacronistic reading
of the text.
It's importing things into the text from
your current vantage point.
Revelation was written to an arguably
first, maybe second century audience.
Either way, this idea that John was
writing to them about denominations that
would spring up in the 16th, 17th
centuries just so ridiculous.
That has nothing to do with what is in
focus for the seven churches that this
apocalyptic letter was written to.
But then again, that's another faulty
problem.
The Adventist Church believes that the
seven churches of Revelation are
speaking about the history of the church
from within, including apostasies that
happened and spiritual conflicts with
the with the church being a separate
time period.
For example, William Miller was
supposedly the Philadelphia age of
brotherly love
and now the SDAs believe they're in the
Leodysian age with lukewarmness.
So they take these seven literal
churches and ascribe long periods of
time to them and claim that's what's in
view.
So they then say that the seven seals
which begin in revelation 6 cover the
history of the church with each one
covering a different emphasis.
So that assumption is brought to the
text
and that also has to be true
for their interpretation of the rest of
this to be correct.
But TED and other SDA leaders just state
this stuff as fact because Ellen White
and the SDH pioneers believed it, stated
it, so therefore it's fact.
When it comes to the white horse in
Revelation,
many ancient writers,
this is to be objective here, many
ancient writers and down through the
ages, people like Irenaeus, Marius
Victorinus, I love both of them.
Even am a number of modern scholars,
David Chilton, J Leonard,
they see Christ as the one riding the
horse.
Not the idea of it representing ages of
the church, but that the horseman
represents Christ like Ted said.
And the argument tends to be that the
white horse appears again in Revelation
19:11, where we see Christ on a white
horse.
They then claim that white must
symbolize righteousness or purity which
would further underscore this identity.
But I would argue
as many others have that something else
is in view. Okay?
And I'm going to give you my
understanding, which is not completely
unique to me, by the way, and it's for
the purpose not of saying you have to
think like I do, but to show you this
assumption that it's the SDA
understanding and there's no other
biblical way of understanding it is a
facade. Okay?
There are a number of reasons to think
biblically that the SDA church's
understanding is false.
First, the white horse itself is the
only similarity with the vision of
Christ in Revelation 19. Nothing else.
In fact, in Revelation 19:5 and 21,
Christ doesn't possess the bow that's
mentioned in Revelation 6, but a sword.
And that's often associated with him in
the book. Revelation 11:16, 212,
216, 1925,
21,
but the bow never is.
Now, the Adventist church asserts that
the bow represents the word of God, and
they cite Habach 3:9, but more on this
in a second. Nevertheless,
so the horseman's given a wreath or some
translations say a crown.
But Christ wears many diadems crowns in
Revelation 19:12
right after 1911.
Also, Revelation 9:7, it has the evil
figure wearing crowns and conquering.
And it often applies to them in other
places as well. Revelation 11:73:7.
So all that to say, it doesn't
automatically have to be a righteous
figure. Second,
Christ's appearance here is out of
place. It'd be strange for Jesus both to
open the scroll and be its content.
As Ted read, the lamb is the one who
opens the seal.
So he opens the seal, but he's the one
on the horse that's coming out of that
seal being open. Third,
it doesn't seem fitting for an angel, so
it says living creature
to command him,
that's to come, which is verse two,
Revelation 6:2.
And yet the rider on the white horse is
in fact commanded by the living
creature. So Ted read this. He said, "I
heard one of the living four creatures
or or sorry, one of the four living
creatures saying with a voice of
thunder, come."
Christ isn't ordered around in
Revelation at all. He's equal with the
father in authority. Revelation 3:21,
5:12, 22 1, and 3.
Because notice, folks, let me bring it
up here.
notice.
H, sorry, this Bible app got to pop up
here.
Oh, of course. There we go.
Okay.
Sorry. Of course,
it would not be a live stream if some
sort of technicality didn't pop up.
Okay, there we go.
Bible Gateway wanted to do the uh popup
in the middle of the stream. Notice what
it says in in verse one there.
Ted said, "The living creature saying
come with a thundering voice, which is
supposed to be about God wanting to
wanting you to know this today."
But who is the living creature saying
this to? I would argue and many others
would as well, the creature is saying,
"Come to the riders on the horses after
the seal is opened by the lamb, which
brings forth the writers."
It would seem odd that the rider would
be the lamb that's opening the seal,
then being told to come by a creature.
Christ is not the one taking orders.
But here the living creatures are
calling forth the writers, not John.
Now, I'm not dogmatic on this by any
means, but again, it's just another
reason.
Fourthly,
the writer is given a crown.
Says, "And a crown was given to him."
Verse two.
Now I would argue grammatically
this involves a providential giving or
granting which John associates with God
giving permission to evil powers to do
things under his sovereign
administration.
And again the reason for this is the
grammar that is seen repeatedly
throughout Revelation.
Revelation 6:2 48
Revelation 91
3 11 I mean it's all throughout the
book. This is why a large majority of
contemporary scholars do not think that
the writer of the white horse is Christ.
People like Beal, GK Beal, Craig Kenir,
Ian Boxwell, it Beckwith, I mean a
number of people.
And it's not to say that thinking so is
heretical.
I just think that there's more evidence
for something else that better fits into
the overall context of why John was
writing, who he's originally writing to,
etc. And we'll look at some of some more
of those in a moment.
But as for the white horse, the white
the white color could could absolutely
represent righteousness or purity as it
does in Revelation 19:11.
But that doesn't necessitate the figure
itself is a righteous figure. Now, what
do I mean by that?
I would contend, as many others would,
that what's in focus in Revelation 6 is
God judging wicked Israel for her
rebellion against him leading up to the
Jewish war with the Romans and the
ultimate destruction of the temple.
Because it was God doing the judgment
using wicked people to accomplish it,
Rome's conquest would have been
righteous even though it was done by an
unrighteous people.
It was done with God's sovereign
authority.
And you think I'm just grasping at
straws here. This is a pattern we find
in scripture by examining God's behavior
and actions in history.
For example, in a parable prophesying
this exact thing, Jerusalem's
destruction, Jesus calls the Romans his
army. Matthew 22:7. The SDA church
twists the parable of the wedding feast
in Matthew 22 into being about the
investigative judgment.
not even close to what's in view.
And I don't have time to address that in
detail tonight. Maybe we'll save that
for another stream dedicated to what is
the kingdom of God. But
I think it can be conclusively said that
in this parable, it's talking about
Jesus being sent by the father to his
people, Israel,
who reject him. Open up Matthew 22 right
now, folks, and you see if I'm just
grasping at straws here.
It is a parable talking about Jesus
being sent by the father to his people
Israel who rejected him. And not just
that, but they killed the one whom the
father sent. Who's the king?
And then verse 7 gives us the king's
response to them doing this. Again, the
king being the father who sent his son.
And in verse 7, it says, "The king was
angry and he sent his troops and
destroyed those murderers and burned
their city."
The Jews are the one that killed Jesus,
the one that the father sent. God the
father used the Roman armies to destroy
them, burn their city and destroy their
temple in the Jewish Roman wars
culminating in AD70.
So in the parable, Rome and evil an evil
figure is said to be God's army.
That's how the color white could be
associated with righteousness even if
the figure isn't in this case Rome.
God does the same thing in Isaiah 10:5,
Habach 1:6.
He refers to wicked Assyria as the quote
rod of his anger.
But then he punishes Assyria for their
arrogance.
Or like God called Nebuchadnezzar his
servant repeatedly even though he was a
wicked figure, not godly. Jeremiah 25,
27, 2 Kings 24, Jeremiah 4.
But all of that to say, the same thing
is going on here in Revelation 6.
The white color, I would argue, as
others would, represents victory.
That's for a few reasons. Again, take it
or leave it. I basically want people to
see that literally everyone is working
with the same imagery and the Bible. So,
it's really a matter of seeing who has
the most evidence.
This idea that no other possible
conclusion can be deduced from scripture
other than what the SDA church is
claiming is not only absurd, but it's
insulting to the world of biblical
scholarship and people who are willing
to give their life for this word.
First, there are a plethora of resources
from antiquity that reference white as
victory.
You've got Senica. I I mean, Herodius,
all just there's all sorts of works of
antiquity that deal with white being a
symbol of victory. And these works were
written around the same time as the
Revelation.
Apocalyptic literature had guidelines
for properly reading it. It was a very
common genre in the first and second
centuries
and white was often associated with
victory. So that's one.
Two,
the text states the writer goes forth to
conquer. Revelation 6:2, the Adventist
church says this is the apostolic church
successfully going forth and advancing
which was completely pure.
Now, myself and many others would argue
it's talking about a different figure
altogether doing a different type of
conquest. And I will state why in a
moment. But three,
there are places in scripture where a
bow is symbol is a symbol of victory.
Revelation or Revelation, sorry,
Zechariah 9:10-14,
as well as flip side examples that use
the picture of breaking bows as a symbol
of peace resulting from victory.
So, you've got the positive and the
negative on this, like in the psalter,
specifically Psalm 46, 46:9,
as well as 1st Samuel 2.
Now, the SDA church says the bow is the
word of God based on Habach 3:9.
I don't think that's what Habach is
saying in his prayer to God. But let's
concede that it still doesn't
automatically necessitate the word of
God as what's in view in Revelation 6:2.
It could very easily be understood to be
victory using the same methodology of
interpretation they use, which is to
point to the word somewhere else
representing something in the Bible and
then plugging it in.
Well, we can do that exact same thing
based both on the context of Zechariah
9:10-14, which is far more fitting, but
also the negative affirmation of the
breaking of bows in Psalm 46 and 2
Samuel being a symbol of peace resulting
from victory being achieved.
There's nothing in this text that
necessitates their interpretation.
Nothing in the text even necessitates
the assumption that the writers are
different periods of church history
personified.
But again, this is what the Adventist
Church means by everything they believe
is biblical. Cite a verse, claim you
know what it is with absolute certainty
because you have the spirit of prophecy
to comment on it. Case closed.
You disagree, you're going against God,
and you just don't believe the Bible.
And yes, we will be demonstrating this
with primary source material later, but
do you see how that works?
Fourth reason why white being
representative of purity doesn't
necessarily have to be a righteous
figure.
And this is a big one. I would argue the
white color represents the effects of
the writer. Why? This is the case in
terms of conquering. So this white horse
is is conquering. That's the effects of
the writer. It's because the other
horses colors reflect that their
results.
The red represents bloodshed, Revelation
64. Black is starvation by famine. Pale
equals death in Revelation 68, etc.
This was talking about the Roman armies
that would prevail, but it will be God's
doing in using them as a tool in his
hands to chastise his rebellious people.
That is what's going on here. And this
is not uncommon in scripture.
God very regularly uses evil figures to
judge men, calling them his own. On top
of Matthew 22:7, like I said, Isaiah 10,
you've got Judges 9, 1st Samuel 16,
23, 18, 19,
1 Kings 22. This is a common theme in
scripture.
And there are other symbols that
scripture provides that could also be
plugged in that might suit the overall
context of why the book is being
written, when it was written, etc. But
they act like the text somehow demands
their interpretation. And ultimately,
that's what they believe. They think the
spirit of prophecy is Jesus speaking,
giving the infallible interpretation of
scripture. And like I said, we will look
at their own words later showing this.
It's not just me saying this. If you're
an Adventist, stick around.
We're going to get to your own primary
sources saying this. Yes, that is what's
going on here. It's not just, oh, we
just believe the Bible. Like Ted said,
primacy is scripture. No, it's not. What
are you talking about, dude? You are
huffing your own smoke and you know it.
But completely denuting the book of
revelation from history like the SDA
church has done, making all of this have
to revolve around writing themselves
into the story is facious and faulty.
Folks, that is not what's going on here.
Josephus wrote about this in his book,
Jewish War. Read it. Published in AD75.
He documents down how he warned the Jews
that they must know the Roman power was
invincible.
He told him that the power of the Roman
uh that Rome is invincible in all parts
of the inhabitable earth.
John's prophecy is tied to the first or
second century.
Regardless of when you think, you know,
there's the post 70 AD and pre70 AD
camps. Regardless, John's prophecy is
tied to the the first or second century.
He tells you, I mean, Revelation 1 13
226.
And Revelation 6 is specifically linked
to near-term expectations.
How do we know this?
This is a verse that's often brought up
or a section of verses that's often
brought up with the SDA church.
due to the time period at which
this is written, but also due to the
fact that it says that there are
spirits under the altar, which seems to
imply uh their idea of the state of the
dead is is faulty. But notice what it
says,
9-11. When he opened the fifth seal, I
saw under the altar the souls of those
who had been slain for the word of God
and for the witness they had borne. They
cried out with a loud voice, "Oh,
sovereign Lord, holy and true, how long
before you will judge and avenge our
blood on those who dwell on the earth?"
Then they were each given a white robe
and told to rest a little longer.
How long, oh Lord? A little longer until
the number of the fellow servants and
their brothers should be complete, who
were to be killed as they themselves had
been.
How long, oh Lord?
a little while longer.
This book surrounds the coming
destruction of the temple and the
devastation of Jerusalem prophesied by
Jesus exactly when he said it would come
upon that generation. Adventists
Matthew 24:34
caused and brought about by the Jewish
war with Rome.
At the end of the day, the SDA church is
working with the same symbols everyone
else is.
They've not cracked some code that
everyone else is just dazed and confused
on. They love to tout at their
Revelation seminars that they've tapped
into an understanding no one else has.
Like some sort of gnostic fancy.
They'll say Revelation was a closed book
until they came along. Everyone was
confused about it because Satan used the
Jesuits to tell people that Revelation
can't really be understood and other
ridiculous conspiracies.
No, the reality is everyone else is
simply honest enough to admit that this
is a tricky area of theology dealing
with apocalyptic literature from
antiquity, which has a lot of moving
parts and factors.
The SDA church wants to act like saying
such a thing is blasphemy when no, it's
called living in reality.
The difference is they emphatically
assert with 100% certainty that they
know they are correct and they have
God's stamp of approval on it. Nope,
they don't.
Again, they're working with the same
information everyone else is and
everyone else's esquetology has
problems.
Everyone's esquetology has problems. I
don't care what the SDA church asserts.
I know all the major positions and
understand all the problems for all of
them. But the SDA church can't have that
or the whole thing collapses.
Which is why they dogmatically assert
that they think they've cracked every
sign, symbol, number, etc. Because
they're supposedly masters of Bible
prophecy. They know it all. They have it
all figured out. Kind of like how Ellen
White claimed to be shown the day and
hour of Jesus's coming multiple times,
that the time of trouble was going to
come upon that generation in the 1800s
and so on. how she was told that that
generation was the the 144,000 that were
given the day and the hour in her very
first vision.
And then their scholars try and say
Ellen White was never explicit of who
the 144,000 were. Baloney.
We have the receipts of this on our
website. Just type in 144,000 into the
search bar answering Adventism.com.
They are full of it.
Yes, she was dogmatic and definitive
about who the 144,000 were, and she was
wrong.
Meaning, she fails the test of a prophet
yet again. But also,
you guys aren't as buttoned up on your
esquetology as you think.
No, no, no. We're supposed to ignore all
that. You know, they're reinterpreting
and going back to the drawing board. But
hey, they're Bible prophecy experts,
right? Figures on the Miller chart.
Ellen said they were never to change.
Oh, they changed three times. No, no,
no. God gave new light. Present truth.
Present truth. Had his hand over a
mistake and was testing his people.
Bible prophecy expert.
This is why I don't even like talking
about esquetology that much because of
especially with former Adventists.
Depends who I'm talking with
because people have esqueatological PTSD
because of this movement.
Now, all of that to say Ted and the SDA
system make a whole lot of assumptions.
He cites these things like time periods
as de facto statements and then moves
along as if it's all without question,
which in their minds it is. Ellen
White's commentary says so. That makes
it so. Period.
Revelation 6 is not talking about
denominations
or the history of the Christian church
into the far distant future. That had
zero relevance to the people John was
writing to.
He wasn't writing them to let them know
there's going to be denominations
that'll come about in 1500 years or so.
It's just silly.
But the a but the SDA church is able to
glean all this from literally two
passages because they supposedly with
100% certainty know what every symbol in
Revelation is because they have the
infallible interpreter.
It is talking primarily about events
that were soon to take place. God
through John went to great lengths to
tell us. I mean, Revelation 1:1.
It's it's basically the first thing he
tells us.
But the SDA church avoids anything that
has to do with imminency unless it has
to do with the return of Christ.
Otherwise, they have to postpone it
until at minimum the 19th century.
They have to find a way to drag stuff
all the way out to write themselves into
the narrative.
They have to find always have to find a
way to work themselves into the story
because that's precisely what the SDA
pioneers including Mrs. White did.
Now, this does not mean, just as a
disclaimer before we get back to his
video, this does not mean that
Revelation doesn't have application to
any other generation, nor does it mean
the entire book of Revelation has come
to pass yet. But the Adventist church is
reading is in is completely
anacronistic.
is reading in such a way that they can
write themselves into the narrative. As
we're going to see later,
when men and women
do not
compromise truth
in their own life,
the the power of the church is very
real.
God cannot sanctify
error.
The powerful New Testament church armed
with the truth of God and filled with
the Holy Spirit made an impact on the
Roman world.
But now
the scene changes.
The second seal is opened.
A red horse gallops across the sky. The
fourth verse in Revelation 6 says,
"Another horse, fiery red, went out, and
it was granted to the one who sat on it
to take peace from the earth,
and that people should kill one
another." And there was given to him a
great sword.
Let's get the picture now. Satan saw
that he could not stop this triumphal
church represented by that galloping
white horse. It was triumphing
everywhere. He had to do something. So
he began a fierce era
of bloody persecution.
He influenced political leaders to
viciously persecute the Christians. So
the red horse represents
a bloody faith.
We showed this picture previously.
The coliseum
in Rome. Christians
were thrown to the lions. Christians
were persecuted. You see, a white horse
represents a powerful pure truth.
The red horse in the second seal
represents a bloodstained
faith. So from the year AD 100 to the
year AD 313
the Christians were persecuted terribly
in the bloodstained
faith period.
So the white horse apostolic
power and purity the red horse a
bloodstained
faith.
Now, where the white horse represents a
church triumphant, the red horse
represents a church persecuted,
but the church continues to grow.
Satan persecuted it, but he couldn't
stop it. One early Christian writer
wrote the following, which is an amazing
admission of the power of God in the
church. He said the blood of the martyrs
is the seed of the gospel.
All right.
So the red horse
is a bloody faith during time of
persecution.
So says Mr. Wilson and the SDA church.
Notice folks for those who have been on
this channel who know anything about
what's going on here. noticed the great
controversy worldview filling in the
gaps. He said, quote, "Satan saw that he
could not stop the triumphal church by
the white horse. So, he had to do
something and begin a fierce era of
persecution by influencing political
leaders to viciously persecute
Christians." And it pertains to the
years AD 100 to AD 313 when the
Christians were p persecuted. All of
that is supposedly laid out in those two
verses. And if you disagree with it,
remember you disagree with the Bible.
All of that is supposedly just there
right there in the text, right? It talks
about Satan and how the white all this
stuff.
None of that is what's in view in this
chapter, folks.
That would have meant nothing to the
people John was originally writing to.
Yes, you have to take that into
consideration, Mr. or Adventist.
You can't come along in the 19th century
and just read yourself into the
narrative like they have.
Then he had the audacity to quote
Teroleian.
He actually misqued him. By the way,
Tertullian said, "The blood of the
martyrs is the seat of the church, not
the seat of the gospel." But
nevertheless,
I love this quote
so much so that I have it depicted in
imagery tattooed on the back of my arm.
But nevertheless,
Ted, why are you citing the same
Tertullian that in response to the Jews
of his day
wrote this
quote, "Let him who contends that the
talking about the seventh day Sabbath
here is still obser uh let him who
contends that the Sabbath is still to be
observed as a bomb of salvation ation
and circumcision on the eighth day.
Teach us that for the time passed,
righteous men kept the Sabbath or
practice circumcision and were thus
rendered friends of God.
For if circumcision purges a man, since
God made Adam uncircumcised, why did he
not circumcise him even after his
sinning? if circumcision purges.
Therefore,
since God originated Adam
un if God unoriginated Adam
uncircumcised and unobservant of the
Sabbath. Consequently, his offspring
also Abel offering his sacrifices
uncircumcised and unobservant of the
Sabbath was by him talking about God
commended.
And he quotes from Genesis 4 1-7,
Hebrews 11:4.
Noah also uncircumcised, yes, and
unobservant of the Sabbath. God freed
from the deluge.
For Enoch 2, most righteous man,
uncircumcised and unobservant of the
Sabbath, he translated him from this
world, who did not first taste death in
order that being a candidate for eternal
life, he might show us that he may or he
also may without the burden of the law
of Moses please God.
So hold on now.
Why are you citing from one of the
Petristics
that your guys' fundamental belief that
we looked at earlier says wasn't one of
the faithful through all the ages.
He didn't view the law of God the way
that you guys do, nor the view of the
fourth commandment you guys do. So
according to you guys and your
fundamental belief, Tertullian wasn't
one of the faithful through all the
ages. Like I mentioned earlier and said
to remember,
he was an ardent defender of the Lord's
day being Sunday, not the Judaizing day.
Also, this is over a hundred years
before your guys' historical revisionism
claiming the Sabbath was changed in the
4th century by Constantine and Pope
Sylvester.
Whether you agree with every point that
Tertullian presents or not, that doesn't
change history.
The same Tutoleian that countless SDAs
have told me was a pagan, a heretic,
etc.
But like I've said before, when they
need an escape hatch,
they're willing to appeal to people that
they'll call heretics when it fancies
the narrative.
Ted, you mentioned this in light of the
martyrs fed to lions.
You mean like Ignatius
who on his way to be fed to the lions
wrote this.
Buckle up folks. Those who were brought
up in the ancient order of things,
meaning the Jews, have come to the
possession of a new hope.
no longer observing the Sabbath, but
living in the observance of the Lord's
day,
on which also our life has sprang up
again by him and by his death. Close
quote. Letter to the Magnesians. Number
nine,
2 century, turn of the first century.
The same Ignatius that Adventists have
to label a heretic a pagan,
say this epistle is a forgery, yada
yada.
like this site that parents this that
that parrots this the same sort of
historical revisionism that SDAs do.
This is Steve Rudd. He's a a
restorationist Church of Christ guy. But
we're bringing him up just because he's
making the same arguments that literally
the SDA church does. The SDA church
does.
But look what he claims. This is the
identical claim that the SDA church
makes.
quote, "All scholars,"
notice what it says at the top. The 15
forgery forged letters of Ignatius.
He says, "All scholars reject eight of
Ignatius's alleged writings as forgeries
and say the seven remaining letters are
genuine and were written in AD 110."
Some scholars reject them as them all as
forgeries that were written about 250
AD.
The third point, notice what he says.
This is the same thing SDAs will say. We
take the firm view that all 15 Ignatian
letters are forgeries. All of the
letters that claim to be written by
Ignatius are fakes.
Almost nothing is known about the real
Ignatius. See Philip Schoff's comments
below. Ah,
everyone wanting to appeal to Philip
Shaw to try and support their crazy
views. But then notice what it says here
down in point D.
Philip Schoff rejects all of Ignatius's
letters as spurious.
Philip Schoff acknowledges that there
has been a broad and long-standing view
that all the Ignatian letters are
forgeries and leaves the matter to the
reader for to decide for himself. Shoff
does clearly does clearly reject all
the letters as forgeries as can be seen
in his comments. Yeah, we're going to
look at his comments
just like we did a few weeks ago.
And I know that that was a Church of
Christ guy, but the SDAs claim the same
things. They just do so for a different
reason.
Steve is is doing that because of their
of because of ecclesiological reasons
because things that Ignatius and and
what he says regarding the church
doesn't align with how the church of
Christ looks in terms of the Adventists.
It's that epistle to the Magnesians. We
have to dismiss that because clearly it
shows the Lord's day being used by the
apostle, his own disciple,
Ignatius, his own disciple. using the
term Lord's Day to refer to something in
contrast to the Jewish Sabbath. So, it
has to be a forgery. So, it's for
sabotarian reasons. But, we're going to
look at Sha's comments, the ones that
this site omitted,
and we're going to ask ourselves, is
this true? Shoff rejected all of the
epistle the the Ignatian epistles.
So, let's look at Sha's comments on the
Ignatian epistles. This is Dr. Schoff's
history of the Christian church.
The chapter is titled the ignation
controversy. We looked at this chapter
uh or or rather we looked at this book
um the chapter on Constantine a few
weeks back regarding SDA pioneer JN
Andrews completely butchering what cho
what Sha said. The same JN Andrews that
said no one could question Sha's
reliability regarding church history. So
let's do the same with these claims.
After all Dr. Scha has to say about the
ignation epistles. Look what he ends it
with. Okay,
you can look this up yourself, folks.
You can look it up online.
What does he end it by saying?
Again, this chapter
is the Ignatian controversy regarding
Ignatius's epistles that that site was
quoting from that SDAs will often quote
from as well.
What does he end it with?
The only genuine Ignatius, as the
question now stands, is the Ignatius of
the shorter seven Greek epistles.
No, Sha does not agree that all 15 of
the Ignatian epistles were forgeries
like Adventists try to claim, thinking
it helps their case. He agrees that the
seven Greek ones are legitimate, which
is what the letter to the Magnesians is
a part of.
I really wish Adventists would stop
trying to appeal to the likes of Sha to
try and bolster support for their
Judaizing.
Sha is not a friend of SDA theology
folks. They love quoting Philip Schoff
because they know how rep and renowned
Schoff is as a Protestant Christian
church historian.
But he was a tried andrue reformed
theologian, a Calvinist, which the SDA
church despises
with a passion.
Yet they're forever trying to ride the
coattails of my spiritual ancestors to
bolster their Judaizing.
Whether it's Sha, the Waldenzians, and
so on,
these people were us folks, not friendly
to SDA theology. Do not let them.
But ironically, in light of that, here's
Dr. Sha's translation of Ignatius's
epistle to the Philadelphiaians,
which is a very fitting response to all
of this.
Quote, "If anyone preach the Jewish law
unto you, listen not to him. For it's
better to hearken to Christian doctrine
from a man who's been uncircumcised
than to Judaism from one uncircumcised."
It is better to hearken to Christian
doctrine from a man who has been
circumcised than to Judaism from one
uncircumcised.
What a quote.
The SDA church fits the bill of that
last line perfectly. The uncircumcision
party trying to preach Judaizing to us.
And no, that also isn't from one of the
eight alleged forgeries.
But all that to say, these folks were
not a part of the lineage of the
faithful, Ted,
that you guys claim is the lineage of
the faithful. So why are you citing
someone like Tolon
when he wasn't even referring to what
you call the church?
The blood of those martyrs was not the
seed of what you guys think the church
is.
Ignatius was not one of these sacred
defenders of the the seventh day Sabbath
that you guys like to try and claim made
up the real church in the first and
second century. Neither was Tertullian.
This was 200 years before you guys
claimed the Sabbath was changed.
And he uses the term Lord's Day in
contrast to the Jewish Sabbath, showing
that he didn't understand that phrase
the way you guys do.
It's funny. You'll hear SDA say these
things about people like Ignatius. Those
are all forgeries. We know virtually
nothing about him. But then these same
people will say that Ignatius was
actually a seventh day sabotarian.
We know nothing about him. You can't say
that. But he was a seventh day
sabotarian.
And just so we're clear for the
Adventists, how do I know Tertullian and
Ignatius are dismissed as being
Christians by the SDA church?
Ellen White, great controversy.
Yes, great controversy. Page 52.
In the first centuries of the In the
first centuries, the true Sabbath had
been kept by all Christians.
They were jealous for the honor of God.
And believing that his law is immutable,
they zealously guarded the sacredness of
its precepts.
But with great subtlety,
Satan worked through his agents to bring
about his object
that the attention of the people might
be called to the Sunday. It was made a
festival in honor of the resurrection of
Christ. Religious services were held
upon it. Yet it was regarded as a day of
recreation,
the Sabbath, referring to the seventh
day Sabbath being still sacredly
observed.
No, it wasn't. It wasn't made a festival
in honor of the resurrection.
As Ignatius rightly pointed out, it's
rooted in the new creation. It's what he
means by our life sprang up on that day.
The new creation of which the
resurrection was the inauguration point.
Has nothing to do with Constantine
making it a festival. This is hundreds
of years before Constantine even was
born.
So Ted quotes Tertullian saying the
blood of the martyrs is the seed of the
church. But his prophetus says all true
Christians in the first couple centuries
all kept the seventh day Sabbath which
eliminates both Tertullian and Ignatius
from being true Christians according to
her.
And that's a thus sayeth the Lord
statement by the way folks. How do we
know that? Selected messages book three
page 122.
Quote we've looked at this before.
How many have read carefully patriarchs
and prophets great controversy
adventists? There it is what we just
quoted from and desire of ages. I wish
all to understand that my confidence in
the light that God has given stands firm
because I know that the Holy Spirit's
power magnified the truth and made it
honorable saying this is the way. Walk
ye in it. In my books the truth is
stated barricaded by a thus sayeth the
Lord. The Holy Spirit traced these
truths upon my heart and mind as
indelibly as the law was traced by the
finger of God upon the tables of stone
which are now in the ark to be brought
forth in that great day when sentence
will be pronounced against every evil
seducing science produced by the father
of lies. Close quote.
So according to the Adventist God,
Tolian and Ignatius weren't even
Christians.
The real church was this small, hardly
known, virtually no record of pocket of
people all the way down through history.
Everyone they try and appeal to to say
these were seventh day sabotarian
torchbears were not. The same Ignatius
alongside Polycarp
were disciples of John the Apostle who
penned the book of Revelation.
Nope. They weren't Christians, says the
the God of Adventism through Ellen
White, a disciple of one of the
apostles.
But we're supposed to sacrifice him, a
man fed to pagans essentially, at the
behest of lions for the sake of the Lord
Jesus Christ. We're supposed to
sacrifice him to a fanatic in the 19th
century who claimed God was speaking
through her that they were restoring the
true church and falsely and she falsely
asserted to be shown by God amongst a
number of things over seven times the
day and the hour of Christ's return.
Yeah, not going to happen.
You are out of your mind.
Not going to happen. Not going to
happen.
The same Ignatius writing 200 years
before Pope Sylvester supposedly coined
the term Lord's Day for Sunday like SDA
pioneer JN Andrews erroneously claimed
in his book history of the Sabbath
which again we looked at a few weeks ago
when he when we responded to Ted's
assistant Mark Finley. Remember this
folks, remember this quote.
Quote, "We have proved that the Sunday
festival in the Christian church had no
sabbatical character before the time of
Constantine, meaning it wasn't seen as a
rest day. We've also shown that
heathenism in the person of Constantine
first gave to Sunday its sabbatical
character and in the very act of doing
it designated it as a heathen and not as
a Christian festival. this establishing
a heathen Sabbath.
It was now the part of popery author uh
poperry authoritatively to affect its
transformation into a Christian
institution, a work which was not slow
to perform.
Sylvester was the bishop of Rome while
Constantine was the emperor. How
faithfully he acted in his part in
transforming the festival of the sun
into a Christian institution is seen in
that by his specific a or by his
apostolic authority he changed the name
of the day giving it the imposing title
of Lord's day
to Constantine and Sylvester therefore
the advocates of first day observance
are greatly indebted
so many errors There's so little time.
We're already at almost three hours.
Wow.
He says, "Constantine established Sunday
as a heathen Sabbath. Yet his prophetus
explicitly states over and over."
Sorry about that. It was his prophetus
that states over and over and over
again, "It was the pope that changed
it."
Early Writings, page 32. Quote, I saw
from vision from God that God had not
changed the Sabbath, for he never
changes, but the Pope had changed it
from the seventh to the first day of the
week, for he was to change times and
laws. Close quote.
So she saw, meaning by God, that the
Pope changed the Sabbath. So which one
was it, Adventists? The Pope or
Constantine?
Constantine was never a pope. Jan Andrew
said he didn't change Pope Sylvester 1
didn't change the Sabbath. He just gave
it an imposing title of the Lord's day.
No, he didn't.
Lord's day is coming from Revelation
110. Goofball.
But back to Ignatius's statement.
Of course, they have to claim that this
letters, you know, is is dated to the
later third century, that it was a
forgery, that he was a heretic
because on historical grounds alone,
this reviews the entire schema. They
can't have something like this being
authentic or their whole pipe dream of
history dissipates.
It throws off literally Ted's entire
presentation that he's giving.
That's this is why they're picking dates
that they are like 313 AD.
But you mean those martyrs that were fed
to Ted or fed to Lions Ted?
Those giants of the Christian faith that
despite the cost were willing to follow
Jesus Christ wherever he led, even if it
meant to the gallows to be lion food.
those Christians that weren't persecuted
for being Judaizers, but were actually
persecuted for their faith in the Lord
Jesus Christ. You know, real
persecution, not simply having your
theology critiqued.
It just never ends, folks. All of SDA is
telling me constantly that was a
heretic. Ignatius Ignatius was a
heretic. And here we have the president
of their church, the highest office in
the organization, quoting him at one of
the breakout sessions of the general
conference to try and bolster their
interpretation of Revelation 6.
Okay?
The more you persecute us, the more we
grow. You see people standing for their
faith, people who were martyed in the
name of Jesus were a witness and a
testimony to so many others. The church
grew. They they said, "Those people must
have something. I need to know it. It
must be the truth." So, Satan changed
the strategy from persecution to
something else.
Let me tell you, the devil is like a
roaring lion. The Bible says, "Going
around who he will devour,
beware.
Stand on the Lord's side and let the
Lord defend you when the devil shows up
at your door." Well, so Satan changed
the strategy from persecution to
something else. And what was that? A
third horse gallops across the sky. This
black horse
represented the period of AD 313
to AD 538.
Let's read in verse 5. When he opened
the third seal, I heard the third living
creature say, "Come and see."
So I looked, and behold, a black horse,
and he who sat on it had a pair of
scales
in his hand. After 200 years of
persecution, Satan used a different
model because what he was using was not
working. The Christian church kept
growing. The blood of Christians is
seed.
So his new strategy,
and let me tell you, he's using that
today
in the church, outside of the church, in
your life, in my life, trying to bring
about
compromise.
Okay, you give a little, I'll give a
little. Let's not worry exactly about
all the fine things about truth. Let's
just make it a bit fuzzy. Don't worry,
let's all get together. Beware, my
friends here in Indianapolis and around
the world, beware
of compromise.
So, his master strategy was, and this
was an amazing way in which he went
about it, was to bring pagan practices
into the church.
So as the white horse
depicted in this beautiful panel over on
your right side represents purity,
the black horse in revelation represents
compromise and error coming into the
church. So this black horse represents
the period in church history from 313 to
538. A
D.
All right.
So again,
notice how Ted refers to the church that
was persecuted early in this universal
sense trying to bolster the idea that
they are somehow inheritors of those
individuals
because that's what all this is leading
to to writing the SDA church into the
narrative as the end times remnant at
the end of this chain from the apostles.
Yet those individuals were not
Judaizers.
They aren't a part of the faithful in
all the ages that their fundamental
belief claims makes up the church.
Furthermore, notice how Ted's reading is
entirely through the lens of the great
controversy. It is all about what
Satan's doing.
They claim to have all this extra
insight into Satan.
So the original audience that read what
we call revelation 6 chap chapter and
verse divisions are a 15th century or
1500s rather addition to the text.
That original audience was supposed to
understand that these horsemen are
different ages of time and represent
Satan using different strategies to try
and attack the church. All of that
supposedly laid out in these verses.
Of course not.
Again, this is ad this is Ted's
Adventist lens doing the interpretation.
Nothing in these verses is about Satan
trying new strategies and long periods
of time.
John is writing the revelation to a
people in his day.
Completely ignoring that to then read
back into the text 2,000 years later.
And what you want to be there is not
sound hermeneutics.
But notice again,
this is all supposedly crystal clear
just from the Bible. It's just obvious
all these arbitrary dates what the
symbols represent.
Nothing in the text tells you with
absolute certainty that these are long
periods of time. This is their
interpretation.
Yes, Adventists, your interpretation.
They simply think that they have an
inspired one which makes them correct.
Which is why like Ted they just state
these things as de facto no questions
asked.
He claims this black horsemen represents
the period of AD 313 to AD 538.
Again just regurgitating obviously Uriah
Smith commentary.
Where's thatly stated in the text Ted?
This is one of my issues with
historicism personally.
It's an arbitrary plugging in of dates
and events to fit a chronology or
timeline one wants to make happen.
Where in the text is this stated, Ted,
that after years of persecution,
Satan introduced, compromised, and
influenced the adoption of pagan
practices by the church. Where is that
stated in the two verses that you It
doesn't.
And I'm not saying whether or not that
did or didn't happen.
My point is the text in reference
doesn't say this. That is your
interpretation.
Yet they want to act like when you
engage with them, this is just what's
plainly found in the Bible. And if you
disagree, you don't believe the Bible.
when in reality they're in the same boat
everyone else is.
There are plenty of reasons to disagree
with the SDA church's bad hermeneutics
and interpretation.
And it's not because you hate the Bible
or don't believe the Bible because of
it.
But they have to have it this way to
write themselves into the narrative. And
that's the key. That's what he's leading
everyone toward. We're not even going to
get through like half of this
presentation. He he does a bunch of
this. He'llite verses and then he just
monologues the script. Cites a couple
verses, monologues the script, and it's
just asserted that this is what it is.
And if you disagree, you don't believe
the Bible. There's no other possible
interpretation because they've mastered
esquetology. They're esquetology
masters. They're the guardians of
esquetology.
So the black horseman is a period of
time personified and it represents Satan
using strategies of paganism and
compromise
but he's still using that strategy today
that time period. That's what John was
seeking to communicate to his first
century audience.
Hey, I know I told you at the beginning
of the letter that we're about to go
through tribulation together and that
I'm a co-laborer with you in that. So
stand strong against what what we're
about to experience in this. I want you
to know that many denominations are
going to spring up in the future after
Satan uses paganism and compromise to
try and divide the church.
As the Roman centurions are about to lop
your head off and tie you to a spike,
crucify you and light you on fire.
Remember that in the future there's
going to be many denominations which are
a result in a tool of Satan.
Yeah, that that's totally what the first
century audience wanted to hear, right
folks? Because that totally had meaning
to them.
This is a common tactic with SDA
leadership.
They will state general truths in this
case that Satan is seeking for
Christians to compromise which people
hear and think, "Yep, that's true." But
then they'll ramble on and on and on
causing people to forget what was even
said and what it was said in reference
to
get you to feel like, oh, like he cited
scripture here and then he went on this
long monologue and through there he
either bookended it or started it with
something that is generally true. Satan
wants Christians to compromise. And
because he said that and then all this
other stuff that sounded like, wow, that
means that's what the Bible said.
No, none of that is explicitly stated in
where he is citing from in Revelation 6.
He cites a couple verses,
states that it's talking about the years
313 to 538, and then inserts all sorts
of extra details from the spirit of
prophecy in a long rambling of
assertions that the SDA church has made
for decades.
Notice what he equated compromise to. He
said it's the work of Satan that people
give a little here and give a little
there. Speaking about doctrinally,
don't worry. Let's all get together.
Ted, this is literally what hordes of
modern SDAs have done.
Adventism is a big tent. The Justin
coups like, give me a break.
You were on the Seeking What They Saw
podcast right before I was when they
were filming all those. You were guest
one, I was guest two. The entire thesis
those guys are putting forth is that
Adventism is a wide, diverse, big tent
operation
with a variety of viewpoints. Thus,
their question was, "What actually is an
Adventist?"
Beware of compromise.
You have heavenly trio compromisers in
your midst. Full-blown aryens.
You guys have people who completely
compromised the long list of Ellen
White's extra biblical additions to the
Sabbath. You have people who have
compromised the investigative judgment
in your ranks. pastors,
the guys on the seeking what you saw pod
or seeking what they saw podcast that
you were on, they don't a number of them
don't even believe the investigative
judgment compromisers
despite Ellen White claiming these
things are the old landmarks of truth
that should never be compromised.
You guys compromised on Ellen White's
holy kiss vision
where she claimed to be shown in vision.
I'll I'll scoot back for my mic.
In vision, she claimed to be shown that
the holy kiss that Paul signs off with
in like the Thessalonians, for example,
was supposed to be an ordinance
normatively for the church
and that it was to be practiced by the
Christian church as an act as a as a
sacrament and an ordinance.
The July 4th, 1871 issue of the Advent
Review, because of that vision, states
that it was the work of Antichrist as to
why the holy kiss wasn't being practiced
as an ordinance, but needed to be
restored.
Yet then in the July 6th, 1957 issue of
your guys's official publication, The
Youth's Instructor, you guys claimed
that despite the holy kiss being f being
found throughout Paul's epistles,
there's no evidence these injunctions
are to be universal in practice by the
church until the return of Christ.
Folks, if you don't believe me, uh
because I know there'll be people that
that that don't that say you're just
you're just saying that you don't know
what you're talking about. You're just
Okay,
answering a.com, folks. Again, you can
type in any part of what you see here
and it will pop up in the search bar,
folks. Type in holy kiss. You this will
pop up. Read it for yourself. Everything
that's in red is hyperl.
It's all right here.
Them papers of the day that aren't even
SDA were documenting down at the time of
them practicing this that it was turning
into frisky behavior.
Their own Valentine's Day issue Advent
review addressed it.
And then it was the word of the little
flock vision in 1847 that was regarding
the holy kiss where she claimed that the
synagogue of Satan knew that God had
loved the little flock which was the
earliest SDAs because they were the ones
practicing footwashing in the holy kiss.
Yet, fast forward
all the way to here, this issue of the
youth's instructor, July 16, 1957.
They're claiming that despite the holy
kiss being found throughout Paul's
epistles, there's no evidence these
injections are to be universal and
practiced by the church until the return
of Christ.
So you guys compromised
on Elliot's vision and admit she was a
fraud.
I could go on and on and on. If
compromise is the hallmark work of
Satan, Ted, you guys are steeped in it.
In your small little bubble, you have
factions and splintering off the rails.
Yet it's Protestants that are confused.
This sort of division is supposed to be
a hallmark of Babylon, doctrinal
confusion. Yet that describes you guys
perfectly.
So Paul was concerned about the
compromises in his own day. In Acts 20
29 and 30, we read what Paul said.
For I know this, that after my departure
savage wolves will come in among you,
not sparing the flock.
Also, from among yourselves,
men will rise up speaking perverse
things to draw away the disciples after
themselves. So wolves
who attack
a beautiful pasture full of a flock or a
group of sheep. These wolves would come
into the church and they would destroy.
You see the teachings of men
would be substituted for the teachings
of God himself. My friends in
Indianapolis, right here in this
performing arts center, do not be
deceived by someone who tells you
something which is not in accordance
with the word of God.
My goodness.
Acts 20 29-30. The irony, Ted.
Ted, Paul is describing you guys.
You guys are a professional steep or
sheep stealing organization.
Your movement's identity is rooted in
this. You're the wolves that Paul warned
the church about who have crept in
secretly to spy out our freedom and
begin proatitizing your novel doctrine
onto the body of Christ,
trying to lead people after a false
Christ and a false gospel away from the
true shepherd. My goodness, man.
John 10.
Those of us who have entered the true
door and sheepfold, which Jesus says is
himself, enjoying the beautiful field of
salvation as we graze our souls at rest
in Christ, enjoying the work of the
shepherd for us. And you guys are trying
to climb over the fence in your sheep
suits to begin trying to lead us out the
door into a fake door that's propped up
at the edge of a cliff.
Your guy's entire mission is to
Christians
the sheep.
It's hardcoded into your theology that
Christians are an abomination to God
because we reject your guys' false
doctrine.
Remember the quotes from the beginning,
folks. If you missed the beginning, you
missed the foundation we laid for all
this. Remember to be listening with that
background information in mind. This
organization is a wolf,
an attacker and accuser and that's crept
in to spy out our freedom in Christ.
Every time I hear an Adventist talking
about false prophets and wolves, I'm
just dumbfounded at the like, hello,
are you serious?
This is the last movement that should be
warning on such a thing.
He he said the teachings of men for the
teaching of God. Again, I'm not I'm not
arguing whether or not that has happened
at all in history.
But oh, you mean like the health message
and the investigative judgment and all
the other novel doctrines that on the
one hand you claim are apostolic, but on
the other hand you claim our present
truth messages that no one prior to you
guys preached.
Like those teachings of men, Ted, give
me a break.
That's why we totally reject your false
doctrine. It isn't in accordance with
the word of God.
You guys claim it is by anacronistically
reading the Bible and trying to to back
all of your 19th century novelties into
scripture.
But again, you guys claim the three
angels messages are a present truth
message that none of the apostles, we
just looked at this last week. I can
show you source after source after
source, your own your own official
source documents
where you have people saying none of the
apostles, the church fathers, the
medieval fathers, or the reformers
preached your message, but it's
biblical, right?
The men that penned the scriptures
didn't preach it, but it's biblical.
Yeah. Okay.
In this period, religious leaders
arose teaching perverse,
crooked,
deviating things. By compromise, the
church became large and had political
power.
But it was weak spiritually.
human tradition
would take the place of the primacy of
the holy word of God, the Bible. Now,
that's a very important point for you to
remember,
the primacy of scripture.
But he told us that Revelation 6 4-5 is
supposedly talking about religious
leaders rising up between the years 3:13
and 538.
But it's actually the strategy Satan is
still using. So it isn't unique to that
time period.
That's what John's trying to tell you in
Revelation 6.
Ted, you guys are the religious leaders
that Satan has used to teach perverse,
crooked, deviating things.
You guys love pointing the finger at
Rome. And don't get me wrong, I have my
theological disagreements with Rome.
But you guys are the last ones that
should be critiquing anyone regarding
crooked, perverse theology.
I guess Revelation 6 4-5 is actually
about the entire length of human history
because none of what Ted is describing
is unique to 3:13 to 538.
That's going on long before then.
This same stuff was happening with
National Israel thousands of years
before.
Ted is doing the SDA shuffle here. He
reads the text, makes a bunch of
assertions, reads a couple verses from
Acts 20 which have nothing to do with
Revelation 6. Follow making a bunch of
assertions. Tada. It's like a magic
trick
that now proves that Revelation 6 is
talking about all of these assertions
and it leading us to understanding that
denominations are a product of Satan to
confuse and deceive people
even though the SDA church wants to be
considered a denomination amongst the
body of Christ.
We responded to Doug Baxer Fable's talk
that was like a 45m minute talk. It took
us five hours to go through it. And in
that talk, he bs and scoffs at the idea
or sorry sorry folks, sorry.
This is a different video. I've
responded to Doug a couple of times.
It's in the ones where I where he he
claimed that Ellen White isn't viewed as
a prophet in the Adventist church and
she's not able interpreter and it's
Bible only, etc. In that same video, he
bs and scoffs at people who say the
Adventist Church is not to be considered
a valid denomination. He says, "Of
course it is. Denomination just means we
have a name on the building."
So in those instances where Christians
are critiquing Adventists, we're just a
denomination like you. But then in an
internal talk like this, denominations
are a tool of Satan.
They want to be considered a
denomination amongst the body of Christ
even though the SDA church has a long
history of years and years and years of
twisting and compromise.
He said human tradition took the primacy
of the word of God. You mean like how
that's functionally what you have done
with the writings of Ellen White who you
guys claim is an infallible interpreter
because it's supposedly Jesus
interpreting the text for us. Here you
go folks.
Here you go.
Like I said earlier, I said I'm going to
bring this up so people can see. I'm not
just saying this. I'm not just talking
out the side of my neck. Yes, they teach
Ellen White infallible interpreter.
Okay.
Review and Herald, June 3, 1971. It's on
page five.
This is the section of that paper of
that review and herald article, the the
source of final appeal where they're
talking about how all Protestants claim
the Bible as their only infallible
guide. Yet, they're all divided into
what Ellen White said, innumerable sex,
just like Ted's trying to position.
They're really just recycling a lot of
Roman Catholic talking points on this,
by the way. But nevertheless, look at
what they say. Okay.
Quote, "In the religious world, there
are many voices, but many of them give
forth uncertain sounds. Where shall men
find an infallible interpretation of
truth?"
Christians answer, notice there,
they're saying this in contrast to
themselves. Christians answer in God. In
him only can truth be found. For he
alone sees all things in their true
light. He alone knows the end from the
beginning. But how are men to know God's
mind? How are they to communicate with
him and receive the information desired?
Again, Christians answer. And I'm
telling you folks, notice Christians
answer, not Adventists. It's subtly
differentiating between them and
Christians.
Again, Christians answer in the Bible is
revealed his word and will. This men
must study and they shall know. But when
the inquirer turns hopefully to this
source for a solution of his problems,
he is confronted with a discouraging
fact. He finds himself surrounded with
several hundred sects of Christians,
each claiming to be following the Bible
as its infallible guide and counselor.
These sects differ from one another so
marketkedly that each surrounds itself
with a wall of separation designed to
assist in maintaining its peculiar
characteristics.
Close quote.
Now see that that's not true.
These sexs differ from one another so
markedly that each surrounds itself with
a wall of separation and that wall is
designed to assist in maintaining its
peculiar characteristics.
That's not what's going on. Not at all.
It's not designed that way. There's the
assumption here that having any
theological differences whatsoever is
unacceptable. The Bible makes no
provision for such. Every single
doctrine is foundational.
It's all a dividing line issue because
that's the Adventist mentality. But
that's not what's going on in
Protestantism.
So again, standard common claim from
Rome in the East since the Reformation.
The SDA church is just regurgitating
that. There's a number of problematic
assumptions here. But then notice what
they say is a solution to alleviating
this. The next section
under a section with the heading how new
sex are formed.
Quote, one of his own one of his own
number in studying the Bible arrives at
conclusions differing from his body of
believers. Still talking about this
hypothetical person who hears the Bible
is is the infallible authority.
Investigation and discussion follow.
Strife and division ensue and a council
is called in the the enclosure. The two
factions are arrayed against each other.
Each maintains his position, at least to
his own satisfaction from the Bible. A
vote is taken on the question and a
majority settle it for the for the
enclosure. The minorities settle it for
themselves. A new sect is then formed.
The wall of prejudice is broken down as
far as inquir is is concerned. And once
each or and once more he is turned loose
upon the uncertain sea of investigation.
This illustrates the fact that most
denominations, there's the word
denominations, at least have no
satisfactory court of appeal, that which
the Bible is infallible and is the basis
of all Christian faith. It needs to be
infallibly interpreted to avoid
confusion and division. Paging Rome,
buzz buzz. Paging the Roman Sea, the
magisterial authority.
This is the identical claim that Rome
has made since the reformation.
The magisterium is necessary to
understand the infallible book because
without having the infallible
interpreter, you end up with a bunch of
confusion and division.
But how does the SDA church propose that
this is alleviated? This is the key.
It's obviously not the magisterium and
the pap the papal authority and papacy,
right? No. No, of course not.
They have no popes and cardinals, they
tell us like William Johnson in the w in
the Walter Martin discussion. What do
they say?
Quote, to be reliable, interpretation
must come to us through the same channel
through which came the scripture in the
first place. But what is the channel
through which scripture came to us? The
testimony of Jesus or the spirit of
prophecy. Revelation 19:10. It was the
spirit of Jesus that spoke through the
prophets. 1 Peter 1:10-11.
Thus,
we go up here. Sorry.
They continue. Thus, the prophets have
always been the living active voice of
God to his people.
And the products of the prophets have
always been the guide that alone the
people could follow to sure success.
This voice has always been its own
interpreter. Thus, when we can find in
the writings of Isaiah or Jeremiah
something that explains some statements
in the writings of Moses, when a writer
of the New Testament explains a passage
in the Old Testament, this is accepted
not as a private interpretation but as
settling all dispute because the
interpretation came through the same
source or channel as the words for which
the meaning is sought. Thus, here it is,
folks. Protestants have always claimed
that the Bible is its own interpreter.
Perhaps it's better to say the spirit of
prophecy. We use the term here as
synonymous with the gift of prophecy or
testimony of Jesus is its own
interpreter.
Ah,
so no, it isn't the papacy.
That's not who gives the infallible
interpretation or the magisterium, but
Jesus supposedly speaking through the
writings of Ellen White.
So that's what we're to trust to lead us
into all truth.
This is the exact same ro argument that
Rome has made that you can't have a
reliable interpretation of the
infallible scriptures because you aren't
infallible. And look at all the
different groups that all claim to
believe the Bible yet disagree.
They essentially argue that because
there's disagreements amongst people,
you obviously can't know the the proper
understanding,
which is the same erroneous reasoning
that atheists will use to say
Christianity can't be true because look
at all the competing religions of the
world. Since there's disagreements, that
therefore proves you can't know which
one's correct. It's just not sound
reasoning.
But different discussion for a different
day. The point being, this is why Ted is
presenting Revelation 6 the way that he
is. He thinks they have an infallible
interpretation of Jesus speaking through
Ellen White's writings, giving the
proper understanding of the biblical
text.
They have simply replaced the papacy in
the magisterial sea with the writings of
a woman from the 19th century that they
that they slap with the label of Jesus
is speaking here. Spirit of prophecy is
found here.
No, no, it's not like the pope or the
magisterium because that's men claiming
to be infallible. We're saying Jesus is
speaking through Ellen White's writings.
It's God speaking, not man.
But she isn't a prophet. Remember folks,
all the SDAs that love to distance
themselves from Ellen White, we just
believe the Bible.
Okay. Well, your church openly states
that you can't just believe the Bible
without having an infallible interpreter
to give you the correct interpretation.
Gee, it's kind of like I've been saying
on this platform from day one and SDAs
will claim I'm lying. I'm confused. I
don't know what I'm talking about.
At the beginning of this talk, remember
that Ted said, "If it's in the Bible,
it's for me. If it isn't, then it's
not."
And he had the audience say it along
with him. Ted, what you mean is if Ellen
White's writings tell me this is what
the Bible is saying, it's for me. If it
disagrees with Ellen's interpretation,
it's not for me.
Because at the end of the day,
denominations being a product of Satan
is not coming from the Bible.
It's coming from Ellen White like we
read at the beginning.
And you believe that that's shedding
infallible interpretive light onto the
Bible. Therefore, it must be biblical.
No, that isn't in the text.
It's coming from your infallible
interpreter.
It is your interpretation.
It's not in the text. It is your
interpretation. You simply think that
you have an infallible one.
So don't tell us you guys only believe
the Bible and B and scoff at tradition.
When you literally have a tradition, you
call the spirit of prophecy and the
great controversy theme to then
interpret the Bible for you.
I mean, you you guys fault Rome for the
exact same thing.
You do the exact thing you guys
criticize them of doing.
You can't say that you hold to the
primacy of scripture when you teach that
scripture can't be understood correctly
without having the infallible
interpreter to interpret it for you.
This is the abject catch 22 that the SDA
church lives with, excuse me, lives
within.
because then the infallible interpreter
is premier over the thing that's
supposed to be supreme.
It's right there
and we could look at others.
You guys have published the same thing
in various publications over the years
as we again have documented at answering
adventism.com.
Look at this. from a Sabbath school
quarterly,
April to June, second quarter, 1976,
issue number 324 on page 92. Look what
it says, folks.
This is them commenting on Ellen White's
Christ object lessons from pages 133
through 4. That's what the study for
this section was.
quote, "How advantaged the Seventh
Adventist Church is to have a modern
what?
Inspired interpreter of both the Old and
New Testaments." Then what do they say?
Surely there is every logical reason to
give the inspired interpretation top
priority in arriving at our
understanding of the word today. Close
quote.
And that's really the core issue, folks.
You can only understand the book of
Revelation, heck, all of the Bible
with the infallible interpretation of
Ellen White.
But John was writing the revelation to
first century people who didn't have her
writings.
Their infallible interpretation that is
novel to their present truth message is
what interprets the whole Bible starting
in 1844.
The organization insists they only
believe the Bible. But when it comes to
being able to understand the Bible,
well,
you have to have the infallible
interpreter to do that. But we only
believe the Bible. See the problem?
Revelation 6 says nothing about
denominationalism and Satan bringing
about denominations as a be as a as a
means of introducing compromise and
paganism and so on.
Ted, just like the SDA church, has
demonstrated they don't understand
denominationalism.
As we looked at, he hoists up a straw
man that each denomination views
themselves like the Adventist church
does as the only true church.
This is false. As we looked at
all these denominations see themselves
as a part of the larger universal body
of believers.
He claims as the SDA church does that
denominationalism is proof that
Protestants are Babylon because they're
supposedly doctrinally confused and
totally divided. Even though our
confessions
align on like 90% of everything,
we all affirm the creeds, affirm the
same God, the same gospel, have the
identically same message and mission,
and view ourselves as attached to the
same universal body that came before us
and will come after us.
Compared to your movement that's not
only riddled with compromisers and
pastors that don't even uphold the
fundamental beliefs, they deny the
investigative judgment. They deny the
National Sunday law. They deny Sunday
being the mark of the beast. They deny
the health message. And on and on and
on.
I mean, they don't even see how
foundational all these things are to
your guys' systematic theology
and that without them, the system
collapses. Yet, they're teaching in your
pulpits.
I mean, give me a break that we're
Babylon. Give me a break. And yeah, I am
going to get a little bit elevated
attacking the body of Christ when it's
just such a joke coming from this this
movement. Look in the mirror.
Yeah, you guys need a stern speaking
tube.
It's all kumbaya around the fire in
Adventism. Everyone patting each other
on the back like everything's fine. And
it's not.
It's not okay. It's not okay.
And with tears in my eyes, I will look
at you and tell you it's not okay
because we care about you.
It's all built on lies. It's lies.
Heck, someone just this week,
this week sent me an orientation video
from Walaw Wala University where they're
talking about people having multiple
gender identities and the gender binary
being a western social construct. But
you guys are the remnant.
Yeah. Okay. Police.
Your own institutions are caving to the
cultural mob and the zeitgeist of the
day.
Lassier, the others, they're going to be
following suit, I'm sure, if they
haven't already.
The SDA organization itself has
compromised even on Ellen White's own
visions and writings.
Again, folks, look at it on our site. Go
look at the sources. There's no
defending this. You can't do the oh,
it's out of context. It's not going to
work, folks. She claimed to be shown in
vision that the holy kiss Paul signs off
on
in some of his letters was supposed to
be an ordinance for the church that fell
away due to antichrist.
But then in the 1960s, they're saying
there's no biblical evidence of the holy
kiss being a normative ordinance and
practice. It was only cultural.
inadvertently calling themselves
Antichrist.
It's like, come on, man. Not so
infallible after all, huh, folks?
Adventists, we want you to come to know
the truth.
You're called to follow Christ wherever
he leads
regardless of the cause. It's not about
being loyal to an organization.
Are you willing to actually follow
Christ? His voice, the voice of the
shepherd is not in this organization
yet. Ellen White is supposed to be the
infallible interpreter. She's supposed
to be the godsend of unity that will
result all of you being completely in
lock step and united across every front,
exhibiting no hallmarks of Babylonian
division.
It's because of this that you have the
remnant within the remnant type of
Adventists who think only a remnant of
the remnant church is even legitimate
because the organization has supposedly
been infiltrated with Jesuits. So the
organization can't possibly be God's.
Satan in these people's eyes has
literally infiltrated God's church.
Ted, you are kidding yourselves. Just
look at the comments on my videos. The
whole trope about Christians being
confused while you guys aren't even
united
is one massive case of projection.
Trying to act like this is something
totally foreign to you guys, exclusive
to everyone else. Yet division and
compromise is literally the story of the
Adventist Church's history and identity.
You just veil it behind present truth.
It's your get out of jail free card to
try and use that as a dust mop to clean
up all the issues which ironically only
causes more.
Protestants are far more united than the
SDA church.
Again, born again Christians do not care
about denominations.
90% of the guests I've had on this
platform aren't Presbyterians.
So what? Big freaking deal.
That's not what we're looking to for
unity.
The denominational name is a descriptor
of certain distinctives that are
foundational that are or sorry that are
not foundational distinctives. They are
tertiary things
like Presbyterianism is is specifically
it only tells you about a a type of
church governance
that has nothing to do with the gospel
or God.
If you're a former Adventist and you've
wondered about this issue, understand
that defining terms is the most
important thing.
Go back to where I brought up the slide
about the three different uses of the
word church. You can't equivocate
between those. There is only one church,
capital C, which is the universal body
of believers in all times and places,
past, present, future. Those people are
found across the board in a variety of
denominations. Yes, even Roman
Catholicism, Orthodoxy, etc.
Each Protestant denomination does not
think that they are the one true church
and you have to on some impossible
expedition like Ted positioned it
undertake trying to find the right one
because Satan has set up all these false
ones amongst the real one as a tool of
deception to try and paint the picture
and bolster that Adventism is this
bastion of unity.
There are great non-denominational local
gatherings, Baptist, Lutheran.
Is the word of God and the true God and
his gospel preached? Are the sacraments
being lawfully administered?
There will be born again believers in
the in in the midst of those bodies. As
you grow from the spiritual milk onto
the spiritual meat, into the finer
details, maybe you'll grow to believe
that one denomination is more aligned on
the secondary issues than another, and
you'll make the switch. I did this
myself.
I was a Baptist for a number of years,
became scripturally convinced of
Presbyterianism, and made the switch.
Did I become a Christian at that point?
Of course not.
Did I begin all of a sudden evangelizing
all my Baptist friends from where I'd
left or the guys that I do street
evangelism with? No. Did the pastors and
elders see me as apostatizing from the
faith? Of course not. Yet in Adventism,
they would.
That is not what's going on with
denominationalism and why they exist.
Now, I'm losing my voice. This went way
longer than it should have. For those of
you that were here the entire time,
bless you. Thank you for being here. I
hope this was beneficial. I know this is
something that burdens so many SDAs.
I'll be doing shorter videos on this
specific topic in the future because
again, I I know that lots of people
leave Adventism and they're confused on
this topic.
So, we're going to give you the
classical Protestant perspective.
But do not listen to the SDA church on
this area. They they do not know what
they're talking about. They are
completely confused. It is all part and
seen through like everything else is the
great controversy theme. That's what
drives everything. this extra-biblical
unique thing that Herbert Douglas,
household name in Adventism, openly
stated and has said, Ministry magazine
December 2000, the great controversy
theme is the equivalent of the God
particle.
It is the answer to the theory of
everything and we've been given it. We
did not discover it. We were given it.
He says in the great controversy theme,
it informs literally everything.
everything in their theology. So
understand this foundational component
totally faulty totally faulty. They
don't understand what denominations are.
The one true church is the universal
body of believers all places, times,
space in uh all all generations. And the
remnant is not specifically the SDA
church. The remnant is God's people in
all generations that are called out from
the world. That's how that can have
application to every generation. not
some special end times thing where they
just write themselves into the the
narrative. But again, if you want to
know more about our our position on
that, go to answering adventism.com. You
can type in the remnant up top. You can
go to the end times section of the site
and you can find our uh responses and uh
sources to those sorts of things. So
with that said, I just want to plug one
more time. Please folks, answering
Adventism.com,
there are resources, memes, videos. You
can sign up for our newsletter. You can
donate and a host of other things. So
please make sure to check that out.
Adventists, we care about you. We care
about you. I'm a passionate person. It's
very obvious, very clear. I'm not
oblivious to that. But this is not a
kumbaya around the fire type of
discussion. That sort of talk happens
once you come to Christ, the true Christ
and his gospel, then we do that. Right
now, you need a stern message. I was
there. I know how it is. I know how it
is. There's no feathers being ruffled.
There's a lot of silence about what
people really feel, what people really
think. And I'm going to shoot it to you
straight because that's what I wanted
when I was in SDA.
The voice of the shepherd is not in the
SDA organization.
Period. Sorry. It's not. You need to be
told that. The message and gospel of
Seventh Day Adventism is not the gospel
of the Lord Jesus Christ.
The gospel of the Lord Jesus Christ
actually changes people.
When I meet somebody who who's
encountered this gospel, they know that
they've encountered this gospel.
That's why when people tell I mean I get
people commenting on my videos from all
across the board. You need to join the
Holy Orthodox Church. You need to join
the Roman. I I get all of it. You need
to come back to the SDA church.
And this isn't what I use for my
apologetic
when engaging with other people and
defending the the gospel of the kingdom
and Jesus Christ, etc. But when it comes
to me and myself,
Orthodox friends, Catholic friends,
you're not going to convince me through
history or any sort of other uh
argumentation that this gospel is not
the gospel because this gospel changed
me.
And you can't argue with that. You're
not going to be able to change that. So,
I'm heralding this gospel
because this gospel changes people
and it can free people from serious
things.
and bring about a radical conversion and
change that when you start to study the
word of God who's giving you the
understanding of what all that is union
with Christ.
It all the dots become connected.
There's none of this SDA nonsense going
on. There's none of this it just this
great controversy theme and and all of
that sort of stuff. So, Adventists, we
want you to know the truth. We want you
to know this gospel. Stick around with
us. If you've been here from the
beginning, we're at almost one year,
folks. And I then I want to get off here
because it's been almost four hours.
If you were here from the beginning and
you're an SDA and you're still here,
seriously,
bravo. You may hate me. You may think
I'm a terrible person. You may think I'm
angry, I'm spiteful, etc. still after a
year of listening. But if you're still
here,
I applaud you.
I applaud you. Keep listening
because ultimately it's the word of God.
It's not me that's going to do it.
That's that's not what we think our our
goal is.
We pray and seek to glorify the Lord
Jesus Christ by furthering his kingdom,
by taking his gospel to the nations and
going to this specific people group who
I believe has been under uh serviced,
has been overlooked, has flown under the
radar, and we have to be honest about
the facts. So, if you're still here
after all of this, praise God, and I
hope that you'll continue to listen and
be challenged by this material.
Thank you folks for being here. If you
stuck around this whole time, thank you.
The fact that you'd listened to this for
four hours, I hope it was beneficial. I
hope that you guys were blessed by this.
We will see you guys again next week
where I will have Richard Foster, former
Adventist
on the show to discuss and respond to
Adventist Pastor Dennis Prieb where we
will be discussing the gospel in light
of the Adventist gospel. So, make sure
to be here a week from uh well, six days
actually. It'll be next Thursday. This
was an anomalous Friday night stream.
So, all of that said, thank you for
being here. As always, until next time,
God bless.
[Music]